Hello, hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
I hope my sound guy is here today because I forgot to save the sound settings for this game.
So, I hope you're here because we got to figure that out later.
Hello, everybody.
I am currently... Oh, my gosh.
Like, last... Yesterday, I, like, passed the fuck out yesterday.
Because, like, you guys know, like, yesterday I had to wake up really early because of the cleaning and everything.
So, like, all right.
Here's the bad news.
So, she did a great job, you know.
But then, like, later on, later on at night, when I had to stay up because I wanted to go to sleep, like, instantly.
But I couldn't because I had a lot of work to do.
So, then I was like, okay, I'll just stay up until it's medicine time.
We're dead.
And then I realized I was like, wait.
First off, where's the syringe?
And also, where is the pill cutter?
So, I had a syringe on my desk.
It's just liquid syringe.
It's not, like, a needle or anything.
It's just there for the liquid, like, syringe for, like, liquid and stuff.
So, but it has... It's marked on how much I need to give him exactly for his, like, the liquid medication.
So, I was like, huh.
Huh.
That's weird.
Where is it?
So, I was like, oh, maybe she just, you know, put it in the medicine cabinet.
So, I, you know, I, like, fucking...
Basically, I, like, looked everywhere.
All the cabinets I was trying to find where the fuck the syringe was.
And I was like, oh, the pill cutter is also missing.
Where the fuck's the pill cutter?
And then, like, I texted...
I texted the cleaners.
And I was like, yeah, no, she did a great...
Because I didn't want them to, like, you know...
I feel like they're going to be, like, really harsh on her.
Like, that was, like, my last resort.
Because I knew, like, the moment I texted the management...
That they're going to be, like...
They're going to be, like, really harsh on the cleaner about it.
Because, like, I had a feeling she threw it away.
But that was, like, my last...
But I had, like, a single hope that she didn't.
Because I didn't really want to look through the garbage, so I don't know.
So I was just like, okay, I'm gonna text him, just to be sure if she really did throw it away.
Because that is my last resort.
Because I really, really, really, really, really did not want to dig through trash.
Is my foreshadowing subtle enough, guys?
A very subtle foreshadowing there.
Anyway, so I texted, and then I was like, no, she did a great job.
It's just that, you know, I'm sort of missing his, like, my dog's equipment for his medicine.
And, like, I'm missing the syringe and his pill cutters.
So at first they were like, oh, maybe check the cabinets.
I was like, no, I...
I sort of checked the cabinets, like, three separate times.
And it's not, it's not in there.
And then the client, and then they texted back, was like, oh, we sort of, we talked to the cleaner.
And, like, she thought it was an unusable, reusable syringe.
You know, like, there was, like, one-time use because it was just on my desk.
And so she threw it in the trash.
I was like, and they were like, oh, and the pill cutter is, like, under your desk.
Well, that's a lie.
The pill cutter was not under my desk, by the way, because I looked there and it wasn't there.
But, like, that's okay.
I could use the scissors.
I could cut it with scissors and a knife.
But, like, you know, the pill cutter was just easier.
It was just, you know, more precise.
Instead of, you know, grabbing some scissors and going, I just, and it was free, too, from the hospital.
But, yeah, anyway.
So, I was like, okay.
So, I got, I got a face mask and I, I dug through the trash.
And it was not the best feeling because she also used the trash bag to dump out, you know, the vacuum stuff and everything.
I, I tried to find gloves, too.
Because, like, I knew there was some form of liquid in that trash bag.
Because I, you know, I, I, like, that's where my, like, leftover, I put my leftovers in there, too.
So, I was just like, I didn't, could not find gloves.
Let me just say, I did not find gloves.
So, but, and then I found, I dug through, I got another trash bag.
And then I put, I, because I didn't think I was gonna go through trash!
I never thought I would have to look through trash!
Guys!
I, I, I, I, this was the very first time!
I have to go through trash!
I, I, I never thought I would have to come to this!
I, I never thought!
Many thinking with super chat!
Thank you!
That's primechocojuicedoki!
Anyway, anyway, so...
I went through the trash bags, and...
There wasn't liquid yet.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
I didn't have to worry about that.
But do you remember what I said?
I was pretty sure there was liquid in there.
Found out later on that there was.
Because as I was digging through it, I was like, I got deeper into the trash bag.
I found the syringe.
And it was, it was, like, covered in some weird orange sauce.
And I was like...
And I was like, this is my life now.
This is my life.
Anyway, I had clean, I cleaned the syringe.
I soaked it up.
I let it dry and everything.
I did all...
I'm like, I did all of this for you, Dad.
I did all of this for you.
For you, you little shit.
Like...
The things I do for my dog.
For my fucking dog.
He's like, for me?
By the way, I was doing sing.
Speaking of my dog.
Um, I was doing sing practice, like, two days ago.
And he was, like, sleeping by my side.
And the moment I practiced singing, he, like, left my room.
And...
And then, you know, at first I thought, like, you know, oh, maybe, maybe I was just too loud, you know?
And then he just doesn't, wasn't enjoying how, because he wanted to sleep and stuff.
But, like, you know, sometimes, he doesn't do that when I stream.
So...
Like, he's still...
He's still here.
So then I was like, okay, let me...
Okay, so I was like, okay, let me try this again.
And then, you know, he came...
When he realized I stopped singing, he, like, came back into my room.
And, like, went back to the bed in my room.
And...
I don't think...
And then...
And then, you know, I was like, okay, oh, I gotta start singing this again.
Like, I...
I...
I have my rest.
I gotta practice again.
I tried it again.
And then he...
He walked out again.
So now I'm scared.
So...
Now I'm not confident anymore about it.
That has had it in the...
Doki, no!
But, yeah.
So I found out my dog does not like it when I sing.
He's just like, alright, time to leave.
Time to sleep outside.
Bye.
Alright, let me see if I open the door.
He'll, like, run away.
Because when I...
When I'm streaming.
No!
See?
He's staying here.
I had the door closed.
So I wasn't sure if he's gonna leave because I started streaming.
Um...
But yeah, Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not to make you paranoid, but for the love of God, never put your bare hands in trash again.
Use glove.
Oh, no.
I know there's nothing sharp in there.
I know.
I mean, I was the one that threw the trash.
I know because, like, um, I barely own anything sharp at all.
So, like, um, not because I'm a child or anything.
Not because, like, I child-proofed for myself or anything.
But, like, I knew there wasn't anything sharp in there.
Um, I'm thinking for the super chat, Gus.
Thank you, thank you.
I also couldn't find any gloves at that point.
But, like, I instantly washed my hands after I was done looking through the trash.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Uh...
What else?
What else do I have to update you guys?
Oh, yeah.
Before, this was, like, unrelated to my life, but I thought it was really funny.
But this is spoiler alert for, like, the ending for Renta Girlfriend.
But...
Renta Girlfriend apparently finally ended today or, like, yesterday.
And, like, the girl rejected him.
I don't keep...
I don't keep up with Renta Girlfriend.
Um...
And...
Oh, it didn't end yet?
Okay.
Because people were, like, thinking that it ended.
Like, some people...
I don't know.
There was, like...
Nobody knows if it ended or not.
Um...
But, yeah.
So...
It got leaked, apparently.
Um...
Oh, the author's gonna make a sequel.
Oh, but they still ended the main story with her rejecting him.
So, I don't really...
I don't ever watch or, like, read Renta Girlfriend.
But I have, like, friends that tell me how shit...
How shit the series is.
And how absolutely terrible it is.
And...
But, like, the artwork's really pretty, apparently.
Um...
The artwork's really pretty.
But the writing is, like, pretty ass.
Anyway.
So...
Apparently...
The fandom's fucking hilarious.
From what I've heard.
Uh...
But...
Anyway.
So...
Um...
The last chapter, apparently, got leaked.
And then, um...
She was like...
Sorry.
I picked my career of being a rentable girlfriend over dating you!
No!
Ahahaha!
And then someone was like...
Bro, that guy spent $250,000 on her.
And...
Ahahaha!
And she's still...
Holy fuck!
Ah...
That's crazy!
Apparently, somebody calculated...
How much...
Um...
How much he has spent on her.
And it was like $250,000 US dollars.
And then...
Like...
And then she picked her career over him.
And by the way, the career is being a rentable girlfriend!
Ahahaha!
Oh my god!
Oh my...
I...
I thought that was like...
Oh!
I was like...
She's like, I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
And I'm like, are you though?
Are you actually sorry?
Holy fuck!
I was reading the replies!
And they're like...
Thank fucking god it's over!
I...
Ahahaha!
They were like...
Thank god!
The evil has finally been defeated!
It's over now!
Ahahaha!
Um...
I just...
Yeah...
But yeah...
For those who aren't...
Sorry if I spoiled you guys about rent-a-girlfriend!
But like...
I feel like you guys could've...
Sort of seen...
Yeah...
I feel like at that point if you read up to there thinking that they're gonna get together...
Like...
I think at that point you've like Stockholm Syndrome'd yourself...
Into thinking that that was the endgame!
Hahahaha!
Um...
Anyway...
That manga deserves to be spoiled!
Uh...
Anton!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you thank you!
Money ain't got no soul!
Money ain't got no heart!
All you need is some self-control!
Make yourself a brand new star!
Mama Oni...
The princess and the frog!
Um...
Manny, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Imagine doing that money- Much money on a girl!
Anyway, here's 5 dollars!
Mr.Brokenbond...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
She got her back and played him like a fiddle!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright!
Anyway!
But, that's all the life updates for today.
Um, but yeah, I ordered...
Before I started to stream, I literally got my food like 15 minutes before I started my stream.
So I was like chowing that shit down.
Because I really, really wanted to order some coffee.
Because I was so fucking tired.
So yeah, I started that story.
But the reason why, I slept like 11 hours last night.
Because of how fucking tired I was yesterday.
Because of all the stuff I had to do.
And also like digging through trash really took up a lot for me.
So I went to bed at like 9pm.
And I woke up at around like...
Um, I think...
Like, I don't know.
I just remember...
I...
I slept for like 11 plus hours.
I was so fucking exhausted.
But then like later today, like two hours ago, I was still...
I got really tired.
I got... I was still really tired.
So I ordered a dripped coffee with an espresso shot.
So...
So I might not be okay.
That's why I have a lot of energy right now.
It literally has one shot of espresso.
And it's a dripped coffee.
So you know like...
You know like the slow drip coffee?
That's when you know it's pure fucking caffeine.
Because I am so tired.
So...
Uh...
But yeah, that's clear.
That's all the life update there is.
But yes, are my sound guys...
Is my sound guy here today?
Because I don't remember...
What the sound balancing is for this game.
Because I forgot to save the settings for it.
So, yeah.
Let me know if you're here.
So you can save the stream.
Gus, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
GamePone when trying to fight for that victory, yeah?
Maybe they are better than you.
Or maybe they have a better monitor.
Doki and MSI can help you with one of those.
Link in the description below.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, nice.
Alright, one of the sound guys are here.
Alright, that's good.
Alright, let me... Alright, Onimusha.
Borgar, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi Doki, I want to thank you in the community for motivating me this past year, even through tough times.
Because as of today, I'm graduating and getting my associate's degree.
And get ready to pursue my dreams!
Congratulations!
Happy graduation!
Yay!
Congratulations, man!
See, guys.
We... I knew our IQ... Average IQ was higher.
I knew it.
Alright.
Let's play some Onimusha!
Okay, yes.
I... Do not remember any of the controls, guys.
Alright.
Okay, let's see.
There's this.
Oh my god, where am I?
I forgot I'm her.
Uh...
Okay, let me figure this out, guys.
Okay.
This.
And then...
Okay.
Strong attack.
And then...
Okay, do I need this, though?
Wait, what is this for?
Oh, wait.
This is for, like, shimmying.
I gotta shimmy here.
And then this is block.
And then I accidentally used my knife.
That's pretty bad.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Where am I?
Oh!
Where is she?
I don't know where she is.
Where is this?
Oh!
I remember this place!
Never mind.
I remember.
A mysterious statue of a woman.
There is a hole in this body.
Okay, so I need to find, like...
Something to open this up.
Oh, shit!
Wait, that's illegal.
I forgot!
I don't remember how to play it.
Never mind.
Never mind, guys.
I actually don't remember how to play this game.
Oh, shit!
Am I...
Am I doing it?
Oh, shit!
Guys, I don't think I'm doing it.
I am...
Oh, my God.
Oh, she gets stuck, too.
Thank God.
Okay.
That's fine.
I block.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Am I though?
Am I actually ready?
Who knows?
I'm not ready!
Oh, please!
Wait.
I think there was heals here.
Oh, that wasn't heals.
That was...
Bro is not ready.
I don't remember how to play the game.
Please!
Alright.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
Okay.
We got...
Wait!
It despawns?!
Fuck!
Okay.
I didn't realize it despawns.
Let me...
Okay.
Suck.
I don't get it.
Why didn't do all that?
Why didn't you do that?
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Okay.
I figured it out.
I didn't even figured it out.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Please.
She...
She thinks she's ready?
You know, as long as she thinks she's ready, then that's good enough.
Oh my god.
Please.
I am not ready.
No!
Oh wait.
Heals.
I don't understand.
Do more!
Why aren't you doing combos?!
Alright.
I don't know why she's not comboing.
It's not me.
It's clearly not me.
Looks like I...
This is a...
Looks like I can play something here?
I don't fucking know.
Maybe a key play?
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
Someone has to be ready.
Okay.
Audio could be brought up a bit.
Alright.
I hope nothing tries to kill me while I do this.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me know if it's better.
I'm sure Jube...
Oh, okay.
So that's for Jube.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's...
You know what?
Let's put that in the second save.
I don't trust myself for some reason.
OH SHIT!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I'm doing combos.
Let's go!
Okay.
Suck.
Ready.
Oh my god.
How did I miss?
Okay.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
Oh.
Suck.
Okay.
How are you missing?
He's right there!
I don't think she's ready, guys.
Guys.
I don't think she's ready.
It's not me.
It's her.
Alright.
Elevator instructions.
Despite repeated requests, the elevator has not been fixed.
This is completely unacceptable.
In fact, it's downright outrageous.
I told you that the turbine on the ceiling isn't turning because there is no wind.
What is the matter with you?
If Lord Nobunaga hears about this, you'll regret not listening to me.
Get this elevator fixed now.
This is your final warning.
Guys.
It's not me.
It's her.
I was doing so well on Jube.
So it's not me, guys.
Alright.
Okay.
I also need to get coughed.
Wait.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm gonna go get coughed drops real quick.
Oh, he left.
Wait.
He did leave!
I knew it!
Okay.
He just doesn't like loud noises.
I knew it.
He did leave, guys.
It's not me.
I mean, it is me.
I had to grab water.
Okay.
He just doesn't like it when I'm loud.
It's not the singing, guys.
It's not the singing.
He just doesn't like it when it's loud.
So it's not me.
Alright.
Let me get water.
It's not the singing I say as I cope.
Alright, I'm ready, for real.
Okay, clearly I can't go here yet.
Where do I go?
Okay, I can do that.
That guy was easy.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
What?!
Okay, that was bullshit.
Alright, nice.
Chop.
Alright, suck.
Okay, where have I not... Okay, I haven't went through here yet.
This is new.
Oh, fuck!
That's fine.
I was ready.
Whoa!
I was ready!
See, I told you!
It wasn't me, it was her!
I knew it!
It's never me.
Whoa!
Okay.
I told you!
It wasn't me!
You suck.
Alright.
Can I go through here?
It's locked from the other side.
This picture is terrible.
I can't even look at it.
What an eerie picture.
Feels like it's watching me.
Look, those artists worked really hard on those pictures.
How is that proof?
The proof is that I'm...
I mean...
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god, nice!
Okay.
Suck.
Please.
No.
Get me that suck first.
Okay, I got the HP.
We're fine.
I got the HP, guys.
We're so healthy.
Suck.
Look at that.
We're so healthy, guys.
See, I told you.
I got it.
I figured it out!
Wait, am I supposed to beat up this?
Okay, wait.
I'll charge this up.
Boom!
There we go.
I finally figured out the game mechanics.
What the fuck?
Wait, am I actually supposed to kill that?
What are you?
What the fuck are you?
I have no idea what that is.
It's just there.
The Oni Super Weapon.
The chief of the Yagu Clan, who descended from the Oni Clan, tried hard to maintain and control of the demons.
The Oni Clan used all of their resources to create a great power known as the Onigenbu and Onigashima.
Although the demons attacked and destroyed the Oni Clan to get their claws on the Onigenbu, the Oni Clan was able to protect it somehow.
It's still hidden deep inside the island.
It said that the only one who has the blood of the Oni Clan can obtain this great power.
Okay, so that's something for Jubei later.
What did I get?
Oh my god, I finally got the fucking map.
I don't remember how to look at the map, though.
It was this, right?
No.
It was...
Oh my god, how do I look at the map?
Map where?
I don't care.
Okay, I got medicine though, at least.
Thank god.
I...
I remember I had...
No more medicine from fighting Mr. Nimbus.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where is it?
No, that's not the map.
How do I look at the map?
Oh, it's the...
Oh, I found it!
I figured it out, guys.
I'm so smart.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Let me boost up the volume a little bit more.
Okay.
Uh...
Alright.
Let me know if that's better.
I remember.
Okay, I'll just charge this up.
That's right.
Okay, I'm facing the wrong direction.
Okay.
Alright.
That's right, for later.
For later.
You have to get close, right?
There you go.
See, I told you.
That's right.
Oh, he's just standing there watching.
Come on.
Get over here.
Eventually, one of you guys have to move up.
Okay, it's like that.
Oh, no.
Wait, I didn't mean you.
I didn't mean you.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
How many are...
Oh!
He's coming closer!
He's slowly moving up!
Whoa!
Shit!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He can block.
Please.
Okay, wait.
Oh, never mind.
Nice.
Is he dead?
Oh, he's dead.
Thank God.
What is this?
Nothing.
See, I told you guys I'd be fine.
Look at that.
Nothing to worry about.
hello.
What the fuck?
What the...
What?
Oh, my God.
Wait, that's unfair.
Wait, that's legal.
Hello?
Okay, I can just block all of this.
Am I... supposed to kill them?
Like... Oh shit, I am!
Oh, this is awkward.
Okay, this is actually awkward now.
Because I'm pretty sure, like, they've created a lot.
A lot of glass.
Okay, they might destroy more now.
Okay, maybe they'll come up here.
I believe.
Oh wait, no, they're all dead.
Wait, it was only two?
I swear I saw, like, six of them.
How is there only two?
Okay.
Wait, poison?
What?
I don't wanna... I don't wanna get close to it.
I just saw, like, a poison thing.
I don't know what made a poison.
Okay, it's just there.
Okay, as long as I don't get close to it, it should be fine.
Okay, stab.
Okay, what is that?
What is that?
Who is making the poison?
Oh!
Who the fuck is making the poison?
I can't tell!
I have locked cameras!
Wait, what?
What's that?
I can't tell!
What are you?
Alright.
Oh my god, I fucking hate off-screen attacks.
I literally don't know what it is.
Like, they're still coming!
They just don't stop coming!
Oh!
And they're attacking from the ground, too?!
Okay.
Let's chop him for now.
That's fine.
Get on the ground.
I know you want to.
Alright.
I should have killed all the little guys.
What are you?
Oh my god, it's you.
It's you.
That's fine.
Oh my god, fuck!
That's not fine!
Come on!
Do something!
Oh shit!
Not you!
I didn't mean you!
I meant me!
He's like, You did say do something!
I...
Oh my god!
He...
Still keeps regenerating!
Please just die!
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, it's like a...
Oh, it was like a giant mantis thing.
What's this?
Looks like I can go into the wall.
Wait, no, not yet.
Alright.
Oh, that's for the main statue thing.
Can I break it?
Okay, no.
That has to be...
Jujuje.
What's his name again?
I already forgot his name.
I haven't played him in so long!
Jube.
That's Jube's wall.
Also, I upped the...
Oh.
Could be brought up even more.
Okay, let me bring up the volume even more.
Alright, let me know if that's better.
I was like, what's his name again?
It's been so long.
I feel like I haven't seen him in so long, guys.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, I didn't think I'd see, like, his little minions, though.
It might not be as fine as I thought it'd be.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I need you to fall down so I can do this.
Not- No!
Not you!
No!
Okay.
Goddamn, the stupid auto-lock.
Oh.
Oh, this guy fucked me up.
Because I didn't know what I was doing.
And that's the only reason why he fucked me up, guys.
There you go.
I just didn't know what- how to play- I forgot how to play the game.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, fuck!
No!
He's faster!
He's so much faster!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Come on, guys.
I'm not playing around.
What I got earlier was a shield.
Oh, I can equip?
That's a shield?
Oh my god, it is!
But still manageable.
Okay, we need that.
That might be a better shield.
Oh, I got a knife.
Wait, is that a better sword?
Oh, it is!
Okay.
That's good.
We need all the items we can get.
Oh!
Okay, that definitely looks like a boss fight.
Right there.
Oh, no?
It's not?
Okay, thank god.
Oh, never mind!
Okay.
I can take him.
I told you.
I knew it!
Wait, what?
Oh!
Wait, he got bigger?
He's like, you killed my brother!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
That's fine.
There we go!
Oh!
Oh my god!
She's okay!
Oh, fuck.
I have to use it.
Guys, it's okay.
She's okay.
She's so healthy.
Okay.
There we go.
I told you guys.
She's so healthy, guys.
She's so healthy.
Oh, fuck.
No!
It's the fix!
It's not a fix!
The fear!
The fixed camera angle!
It was just a scratch.
Alright, I got the sacred flute.
I have no idea what to do with this flute.
I blame the fucking fixed camera angle.
Alright.
I literally walked away because of the angle change.
Do I just use the flute?
What the fuck do I do with the flute?
Oh!
Wait, no.
I was looking at the wrong one.
Dispel it by producing... Okay.
Where do I use that?
Where the fuck do I use it?
Okay.
Where am I?
I guess we go back up.
Oh!
The remaster is back... It's on... Or... Yeah.
The remaster is on the... Steam right now.
Alright.
What?
Jesus Christ.
Stop dodging!
He's like, hey guys, what you guys doing?
That poor... That poor guy.
He just wanted to say hi.
He got hit by the collab.
I'm ready.
Okay.
He's like, hey guys.
Oh my god.
No!
You stupid bug!
Okay.
There you go.
He's still dead.
Oh!
Oh, Dokimusha.
Bring... More!
Okay.
I'll bring up even more.
Alright.
I brought it up even more.
Okay.
At least these guys aren't like annoying.
They're just... Okay.
Never mind.
I say that and then one of them is like, I'm not annoying!
I'll show you!
I'll fucking show them all!
Okay.
Yeah.
Are you happy now?
You got your one hit?
Are you happy?
You little fucker?
Alright.
Let's go this way.
I have to go back up.
Enter the wall.
Does that mean if I play my flute here, it opens?
Where would my... Where would the flute work for?
Okay.
I can't use that here.
Where do I use it then?
I guess up... Back up top?
I don't know where to use it.
Wait.
Wait, does the XP I get from these guys go back to Jubei?
I just want... Want to be sure.
Yeah, but who the fuck is... Golgantris?
Who the fuck is that guy?
Oh, it does.
Okay.
I was gonna say, is it worth fighting all these guys?
God, I hate backtrack.
I just want to go straight!
Oh, fuck.
It's him again.
This guy I hate.
This guy I hate so much.
Oh, nice.
Oh, never mind.
Wait.
Why is he so weak?
Why are you?
Are you just like... You just forgot to roid up?
Oh, no.
He roided too much.
I heard like... If you use too much... Um... steroids... Like, it doesn't actually do much for you.
It's too much.
And also, it makes your peepee smaller too, apparently.
Holy fuck!
Stop dodging!
All right.
Nice.
Where do I go?
Some fun facts.
Uh... Okay.
I go that way?
Wait, there was a shortcut over there?
Are you...
Oh, my God.
Oh, I gotta bring up just a little bit more?
All right.
Here you go.
Where the fuck do I have to go?
I'm so lost.
Here?
Where is here?
There's something over here?
No?
There's like a little door over here somewhere.
I don't know where it is.
Okay, I got one of them.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, item!
Oh.
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, guys!
Wait!
Yay!
Oh, it was just a dagger.
Okay, that's fine.
Stop!
Pause!
I gotta grab item!
There's like...
But why is it even accessible in the first place?
There's something here.
Because like, it says there's...
Oh, my God.
That's where the shortcut was supposed to be.
And I missed the shortcut.
All right.
I guess there has to be something over back here then.
Okay.
Oh, this sword does more damage.
Are you fucking...
Please.
Why did you have to get up?
Yeah, this sword definitely do more damage.
Okay.
Save.
Just in case.
Where are you supposed to go, woman?
I don't remember...
Where does...
Oh, I have to bring him the flute!
But how do I get back?
Okay.
Jube, I got the flute!
I forgot...
I forgot I could leave at any time I want.
Oh, my God.
I could leave any time I want.
I thought I was locked in.
My mother...
Even in the afterlife.
She thinks of you.
You can defeat the demons.
It's not like Jubei where like, I'm stuck here forever.
She has her own free will.
Oh, I'm so sad.
Apparently, I could never go back to the village.
That was like, the one time.
That was the one time.
But they're like, you can never go back.
He actually meant it.
He was like, you can only pick one.
And apparently, I definitely, I picked the wrong choice.
The wrong woman.
Because I got greedy.
Why do I always get greedy, guys?
I picked the wrong woman.
And I can't go back.
Nice.
At least I got more souls.
I'm so sad.
I can't believe I actually picked the wrong.
Is it worth upgrading my armor?
Or should I just keep upgrading?
Should I just keep upgrading?
Jesus Christ.
There's archers now!
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
That's it.
I'm using magic.
That's how much I hate you.
Oh my God.
I can't even get these archers.
They're so far up.
I can't even get them.
Okay.
All right, guys.
Is it worth upgrading my armor or nah?
I don't know.
But I need to know first.
Okay.
Let's grab the new sword.
I just need to know if it's worth it first before I try.
Okay, it's a hammer.
Let's grab this hammer.
No, just don't get hit.
You're right.
You're so right, guys.
Just don't get hit, guys.
It's just that easy, everybody.
Okay, I should upgrade the hammer though.
Oh my God.
I don't even have enough.
Okay, that's fine.
I don't even remember like where I have to go.
Where I have to go.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Holy fuck!
I'll take that.
That was on accident too.
I literally accidentally did a perfect parry.
And not mean to.
He like jump scared me.
And I was like, Fuck.
Oh, fuck.
All right.
Okay, so I think I have to...
Oh, I have to go back to the...
What was it?
That area.
Over there.
No, not here.
I have to go here.
The area with the...
Uh...
Yeah.
With the little door.
Oh, shit!
That's fine.
Okay.
Boom.
Oh, shit.
Wait, you're alive?
Woo!
JK!
It's just an...
Ah!
I'm so sorry!
I didn't mean to!
Jesus Christ!
Oh, he still has so much HP!
No, I wish I had my perfect parry!
Oh my god!
Guys, I missed my perfect parry.
Now I know how strong they actually are.
Okay, I actually hate this.
I don't like this weapon.
Uh...
Let's try it.
Let's do this spear.
Oh my god, there's more of them.
Oh my god!
There's...
And there's...
Are you serious?
Oh!
This stupid fucking archer.
Alright, that's fine.
Get out.
Stupid goddamn archer.
The fucking archer, of course.
Oh, please tell me he's not here.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
These guys are fine.
I...
Every time!
Every...
Every fucking time!
I swear to god.
Please!
I was so used to using the girl!
I forgot to use the man!
I was so used to her!
I like figuring out her moveset and everything!
Oh my god, please.
Please!
Okay, we're fine.
I...
It's okay.
We might be...
We're okay.
See, I told you.
It's this way.
I told you guys!
We're so healthy!
We're so okay!
All right, at this point, sound guy, you should have said, bring it up a lot more.
We're doing a little violent...
Oh, shit, nice.
All right, here we go.
Now we figured...
See, look at that.
Oh my god, you're here too?!
Oh my god, not him!
Why did you use magic here?!
Okay, this is where we needed the magic.
Oh my god!
Please.
Oh my god, that's fine, that's fine.
We need it.
It's fine that he hit us just a little bit.
So I could do this.
Cornado!
Okay, now I don't have any more.
I think I have one more magic!
I do!
Boom!
There you go.
I knew it eventually.
Eventually he dies.
There we go.
What?
What shot me?
I swear to god, if I...
Wait, what shot me?
What's still...
What is there to shoot me?
All right.
That might be a little overkill, but I'm angry.
What is it?
Wait, what?
Oh my...
He's on the other side?!
How is that fair?
You're not even like...
Like, I can't even access that!
How is that?
Your stupid plant!
All right.
Oh my god, he's so fucking stupid.
I know, he like literally wall hacked me for no reason.
Okay, there we go.
Give me your souls.
Okay, circle key.
Where the fuck does that unlock?
I'm so...
Like, where is that?
Where the fuck is the circle key for?
Oh, there you go.
I opened it.
Oh no!
No!
Get me out!
I need to kill your archers!
Get me out of here!
They need to die first!
Okay.
No, no, no!
It was worth it!
Shit.
Okay, I need to use this.
I can't.
Like, I have to use that.
It was an emergency.
Where the fuck does it?
The circle key goes in the circle, old Doki.
Okay, where the fuck is...
All right, so it's up here?
I guess it's up here, right?
Should be.
I can't.
No!
He still hits me!
I thought I was being clever!
He still hits me.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, I'm so low.
That's fine.
I won't.
I just need to not get hit by these guys.
By the archers.
Just... Okay.
Just in case I'm stuck in the loop, let me put it at number three.
Just in case.
Okay.
I was scared.
Ah, no!
Okay.
We're still okay.
Just don't get hit.
Alright.
Just remember what they say.
Just don't get hit.
Guys, I think maybe... No, we can live.
We can live.
There's still... There's still hope for us.
There's still hope.
Guys, I have one medicine right now.
I just... I don't know.
I just... I really don't want to use it.
I really don't want to use it.
Until we're ready.
Okay.
Is that circle enough?
No?
Oh, maybe here.
Oh, fuck.
Please don't hit me.
Okay.
We're fine.
Please don't hit me.
Oh, God.
No!
Oh!
Just... Okay, we live.
We still live.
We're still okay.
It's okay.
Alright, we're cutting it a little close.
But we're okay.
Oh my god!
Okay, you scared me a little.
Alright, look.
See?
We did it.
Living on... What the fuck?
Where does this key go?
It's not anywhere here.
Okay.
Where could the circle be?
It's... What's the other room?
The place with the ceiling fan?
The elevator?
Oh, I didn't notice there was a keyhole there.
Okay, it's the elevator.
Okay, we're not... I'm scared of the archers.
I'm so scared of the archers.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Here?
Where would the keyhole be?
That's the ceiling fan.
Oh!
Win magic!
Oh my god!
That's what fans are for!
That's what win does!
Oh my god!
That's so smart!
What if I didn't have magic?
That's actually really smart.
I was not thinking about that.
No way!
Wind produces wind?
Okay.
Oh my god!
Why does it lock like that?!
Okay, this is like my biggest gripe about this game.
I... Like if there's more than one enemy, I literally... I can't lock... I can't like do a final blow.
That's actually such a huge gripe.
Oh.
Whoops.
Wait, wasn't there a staircase behind me?
Yeah.
I knew.
I was like... I remember seeing a staircase up here.
Haha, can't catch me.
I'm on a ladder.
Oh, okay.
That's a circle.
A circle key.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
It's circular!
Okay, guys.
Look.
It was circular.
What's this?
What is that?
Friendly?
Are you...
Oh!
He was not friendly!
He's not friendly!
I don't know!
Oh, shit!
He is definitely not friendly!
He's not...
It's Robocop.
Okay, look.
How was I supposed to know?
Jesus!
What the...
Wait, he hit himself!
Idiot!
Oh, my God!
They're taking your... Oh, my God!
I did not mean that!
Oh, I'm sorry!
Sorry!
Okay, nice.
Jesus Christ!
What the fuck?!
Okay.
That should kill him.
Alright, nice.
And that gave it zero HP.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that took a lot of my HP, guys!
Oh...
No, you saw him!
He hit first, guys.
He definitely hit first.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It's not my fault.
It was self-defense, chat.
Uh...
Um...
Oh...
Uh...
Oh!
Whoops!
Oh, I figured it out!
Oh, this one.
Okay, not like that.
Okay, I figured it out.
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
Gun!
Oh my god, I got gun.
I'm hanging by the thread, but I have my gun.
This is it.
Nothing can stop me now.
I don't remember how to use the gun.
I don't remember how to use the arrow.
But don't worry, nothing can stop me now.
I have a gun by my side.
Okay, but how do I progress?
Puzzles might stop me.
Oh, I need that.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, I guess I'll take the magic, I guess.
What's this?
Oh, I know how to do this.
Okay, 15 plus 14 is 29.
So, 30, 31, 32, 33.
Okay.
Maybe?
And then...
12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24.
That's 24.
Wait, no, that's 24.
Okay.
And then, 10.
Okay, and then...
Look guys, I'm using my fingers to count.
21.
22, 23, 24.
Wait...
Wait, that doesn't make sense.
Wait, 21.
22, 24.
Or... Wait, no.
Wait.
I think I fucked up already.
Wait, no, I didn't.
Because it locked in.
Wait.
But... That doesn't make sense.
Wait, but... I don't have another ten.
I don't have another ten.
Can I reset it?
Oh, I can!
Okay.
So, I'll put one here.
And four here.
Okay.
Twelve, thirteen.
Fourteen, fifteen, sixteen, seventeen, eighteen, nineteen, twenty, twenty-one.
And then we'll put the thirteen here.
And then we put the ten here.
And then... Twelve... Twenty-one.
Is that twenty-one?
Three, three, fifteen, sixteen, eighteen, nineteen, twenty-one, twenty-one.
Twenty-two, twenty-three, twenty-one, twenty-five, twenty-six, twenty-seven.
Twenty-eight, twenty-nine, thirty, three, one, thirty, two, thirty, thirty... Okay.
Seven.
Yay!
Fingers!
Rick!
Who needs a calculator when I have my hand?
Alright.
Nice.
What's this?
I have a scarlet jewel?
What?
What is the circle key for?
What is this key for?
What does the circle mean?
Alright.
I might eat meat abacus.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Oh my god.
There's no save point anywhere.
Uh, Guildenstern's book.
Alright.
What does it say?
Dear Lord Nobunaga, I'm wondering if you approve of the golden evil statue that was completed the other day.
As one of the best engineers in the demon world, I designed it and directed it according to your plan.
It is my opinion that the late king of Fortinbras would never have thought of such a perfect plan.
I enjoyed the project very much.
If you have any other requests, please do not hesitate to let me know.
I promise I will devote my heart and soul to any project you send my way.
What a great name for a statue.
Not just a golden statue.
It's an evil golden statue.
Got you.
So you know.
You know it's particularly evil.
Alright.
Yeah.
Let me double check something real quick.
Okay.
I unmute myself a little for a sec there.
Because I have to blow my nose.
And sometimes when I have to mute myself and unmute myself.
Oh my god.
My HP is so fucking low.
It doesn't go down.
It like fucks up the audio.
Is it worth fighting these guys?
Okay.
As long as I don't hit him.
I don't think it's worth fighting these guys.
They seem like very mad.
Yeah.
Oh wait.
Wait.
They are friendly.
Guys.
Why didn't you tell me to hit him?
I can't believe you told me that hurt innocent workers.
Alright.
This must be for the goal.
This must be for the golden key.
Okay.
And then just jump across.
Right?
Oh look.
There are the workers.
Oh is this?
Oh my god.
That's what the circle key is for.
Recently, my lord has become extremely busy with managing the demon planning human hunts.
Visiting the renovation site at Onigashima.
And constructing the tower of Gifu Castle.
Since I am but a mere human, it's too difficult to keep up with my lord.
But thanks to my lord's brilliant piece of equipment called the light path, I can instantly travel between Onigashima and Gifu Castle.
Now, I can travel and devote my full service to the lord.
Oh, he's like the token human in the demon army.
Okay, so...
This is easy.
My god.
What the fuck?
This is...
What is this?
A puzzle made for children?
Like...
Alright.
Light path.
TP me to Gifu Castle!
How do I get back?
Wait.
How do I get back home?
Instructions unclear.
Okay, this game was...
When this game came out, wasn't this game like rated R or some shit?
This game was not for kids.
Okay, oh my god.
Six?
Fucking no.
Okay, I think I fucked it up already.
How the fuck do I send it over?
What?
Oh, rated M.
Okay.
Yeah, so this game was rated M.
How the fuck?
Okay, this puzzle is...
This puzzle is a lot harder than whatever the fuck I did last puzzle.
How the fuck do I send that to the other side?
I don't fucking know.
I don't...
What?
How do I send this to the other side?
Oh my god, okay.
I don't know.
I...
I don't...
I don't know.
How?
Oh my god, okay.
Think Doki, think.
I'm thinking.
I'm giving it all that I got.
Which isn't a lot.
But, like, it's the effort.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Okay, I figured it out.
Guys, I...
I already forgot how...
I... I...
Guys, I fucked up.
I...
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I think I figured it out, though.
Okay, wait, wait.
I figured it out.
Wait, wait, wait.
I figured it out, guys.
Okay.
I...
Okay... I understand though.
I understand.
Okay, wait, wait, wait...
Okay, I understand, I understand.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
No, no, this all makes perfectly clear to me.
Okay.
Everything is very clear to me on what I need to do.
Very, very clear.
Oh, fuck.
I... I... Fuck!
Fuck!
Okay.
I don't even know how I did that.
How the fuck... How did I do that?
No, I did it again!
I did it again.
No!
Okay.
If I... If I do... This?
Oh my god, it's not even a shape anymore.
It's not even a shape anymore!
I... I don't... I... I... I...
Okay.
Wait.
Alright.
But... Maybe... I move this leg here.
Then how do I get to the other side?
How do I... How do I... How do I get to the other side?
I'm trying to make it travel around the world!
It's not even a shape anymore.
It's not even a shape!
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
They... There's an arrow guy shooting at me because I took so long!
He was like... He's like, please.
Please finish this puzzle.
Sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She did, in fact, not figure it out.
Maybe like this.
Maybe like this?
Then what do I do with all these shapes?
What do I... What do I do?
Maybe like this?
Maybe like
this?
Maybe like this?
Maybe
like this?
How did I do that?
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I feel like I tried every fucking combination possible.
Oh my god, I made it back where it was before.
I'm overthinking it?
No, I made it back.
It's the same thing.
It's the same...
How did I do it?
How did I... How did I make it?
I don't know how I did it.
I was so close.
No.
No, that's the worst part.
When you were just there.
When you were just right there.
Oh, I made the bub...
No, what did I do?
What are you?
What the fuck are you?
I'm trying!
Why did he give me so many moves?
Why
would they do this to me?
This sucks.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I
did it again!
What did I make?
I don't... I don't even know what I made.
Please finish the puzzle.
I haven't seen my family in years.
Sorry.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't even know what I made.
I did the same mistake again!
Oh yeah.
I know.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I can do this.
She, in fact, couldn't do this.
What did I make?
What... What did I make?
Oh my god.
It's so... It's so abstract.
What the fuck did I make?
I'm trying... I'm trying... I'm trying my hardest.
I swear to god.
My brain is cooking as much as it can cook.
What am I making?
I just... Just flip it.
If it was a mirror, it would...
It's just becoming a blur.
Everything is just becoming a blur.
Where was that supposed to go?
Where is that supposed to go?
What shape are you anymore?
What shape are you?
Oh, I did it.
Nice.
What the fuck?
Yay!
Girl, thank you for the... Thank you for the rain.
Thank you for the rain.
Now you die.
First try.
Yay!
We did it.
Oh my god.
That's just almost as sad as me doing that puzzle.
We actually fucking did it.
Holy fuck.
I thought I would never leave.
That was actually the hardest part of this game.
The entire game, that one was the hardest part.
The green wedge.
Alright, at least I'm granted with HP.
Combat in my puzzle game?
I know, right?
Like what the fuck?
Oh yes, it's maxed.
Okay.
I didn't play Onimusha for action.
We're actually free.
Yeah, we did it.
I was like, oh yeah, we did it.
As if I wasn't stuck there for like 20 years.
The green phantom realm?
Where the fuck is that?
I don't even know how I did it.
I honestly...
I don't even know how we did it.
I...
I legitimately...
Can't even tell I did it.
It's all like an actual blur to me right now.
I'm so impressed with what my lord has done these past few days.
Recently he has killed not only the monks, but also the women.
Oh, so impressive.
Wow.
You killed defenseless women and children?
Oh my god.
I'm so impressed.
The hardest things to kill in life.
He has no feelings or morals when it comes to the lives of humans.
And now, it's perfectly obvious to me that Odami Castle will fall.
Who else could conquer the entire country except for my lord?
It is wise for me to decide to serve him.
If I follow my lord, I'll become rich beyond my dreams.
Clearly the hardest enemy of all time.
Women and children.
Nice.
Oh.
Is it worth going through here?
Okay.
But there is like something over on the other side.
I'll make sure.
What's on this side?
And...
East map.
Okay.
I'll go to the realm...
Burr, actually?
I don't know.
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go to the portal.
And I feel like...
Maybe?
Not only the monks, but the war monks and the child monks.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Gus.
Okay.
That should be what the green wedge is for.
Alright.
I don't know where it's gonna take me.
Do I do this or do I go to the other side?
Guys.
I don't know if I should do this part or like the other side first.
Do it?
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It gives me good equipment.
Okay.
We need that.
Yeah.
I need that.
We definitely need that.
Oh.
It's like a little...
It's like a challenge area.
Okay.
I get it.
Alright, let's do some...
Whoa.
Oh, it's like...
Oh, fuck.
Alright.
I don't wanna waste...
My magic here.
If this is like a challenge area.
I feel like it'd be a waste.
If I use it here.
Oh, fuck!
Come on, guys.
Let me beat you up, guys.
It'll be so funny.
You can join your family and friends.
They're all there anyway.
It's better to do...
Do that than be lonely.
Being the last survivor.
Wait.
We go down.
Cause that's where hell is.
Okay.
Come on.
It's easier to be dead with your family and friends.
Than be alone.
Be the last of your kind.
Look at like...
What's his name?
What was that turtle's name?
Lonely George?
Come on.
You don't wanna be lonely, George.
Jesus Christ.
So lonely.
That it?
No.
Thought you could get away, didn't you?
That it?
Where's the last guy?
Hello?
Oh, there he is.
He's like, no!
No!
Oh wait.
Oh, you have a wife!
Don't worry.
You...
You had a wife.
Alright.
Suck.
Proceed.
Okay.
I don't think I need...
You know what?
Fuck it.
I really can't be bothered.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Alright.
Hit me.
Okay.
Oh no.
Okay, maybe I should...
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Uh...
Let me use this real quick.
Oh shit.
Okay.
I wanted to freeze both of them.
Guess not.
Woo!
Hit.
Oh nice!
Got your friend!
Friendly fire!
I love it when there's friendly fire.
I'm like 1 HP.
This is bad.
Alright.
I have to use all my abilities here.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh nice!
He got sucked in too!
That's actually good for me.
Okay.
Oh thank god.
Alright.
The win did so much there.
Thank god.
That win actually was OP there.
Okay.
Nice.
Suck.
And they come in one by one too.
Which is the best part.
Okay.
Nevermind.
They used to come in one by one.
Nice.
I have like range for that.
I can grab multiple.
Alright guys.
You know what would be great?
If you give me a little bit of the yellow.
Just a little bit of the HP.
Come on.
It won't hurt.
Oh shit.
Proceed.
A little...
Just a little bit.
You know?
Oh no.
Assume...
There you go.
Just come on.
It would be so silly if you could give me...
Just a little bit of that HP yellow.
Wouldn't that be a little silly?
It would be so silly.
Okay.
I don't like those...
These guys.
So...
Oh I don't have enough.
That sucks.
I don't have enough for it too.
Oh fuck!
Didn't have...
Oh nice.
Okay.
Alright.
I got the little bit of the...
The yellow.
They don't wanna be silly.
Okay.
Oh!
When there's like multiple, I need to use this.
Now I know though.
If I have multiple, I have to use this.
I don't wanna be silly!
I wanna be serious!
Well too bad.
You should have thought of that before you went to silly school.
Oh nice.
Oh fuck!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
That was a very manly scream.
You shouldn't have been...
You shouldn't have been an undecided major for so long!
Now you gotta go and be silly!
Okay.
Alright.
Got that guy up.
Oh!
Oh nice.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
It takes so long!
How many are there?
Please!
I swear I killed like an entire family at this point.
Entire generation is gone now.
Get out!
Welcome to...
It's like it's hell or something.
I had that...
Went through...
Five floors, right?
Okay.
This feels like fucking five floors.
What?
I'm mad.
That should have hit.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
There's more of you!
No!
Okay.
It's fine.
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh!
It's fine.
No!
Oh my god!
Okay.
This is a little scary, but I do not wanna use...
I really, really don't wanna use my...
My HP.
Oh my god.
I don't wanna use it.
Okay.
That's five.
That should be the last floor.
You guys told me it was five floors!
Oh, hey, Madison.
Wait, is this the fifth floor?
Wait, are you the fifth floor?
I can't...
Guys, all right.
All right.
I have to use it.
I have to.
Okay.
Oh, my... Okay, thank God.
Oh, wait, that's actually a good timing that I used it there.
That's actually incredibly good timing.
Holy fuck.
Oh, oh, oh.
Where am I?
No.
It could be that item.
Oh, my God.
What am I gonna do with mushrooms?
All right.
Is that it?
No, I still have one more guy that wants to fucking turn.
That wants to...
Oh, my God.
There's another one.
Okay.
No, I wasn't supposed to...
No!
Why did it auto-hit?
So many things went wrong!
No!
Oh, my God.
You said five!
I'm pretty sure I'm on 5.3!
Alright, you guys lied.
You said five.
This feels like it was actually... Sorry, Doki.
It was actually a 10.
I was gonna say, I'm pretty sure I'm at like 5.5 right now.
This does not feel like five.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my God.
Five and five.
Oh, sorry.
I just forgot to plus the other five, I guess, guys.
Right?
My bad.
I forgot to finish reading it.
He meant five plus five.
Very easy mistake.
I can only count the four.
I... I... Oh, my God.
He still got... Okay, thank God.
He still got hit.
I was gonna say, oh, thank God.
Woo!
Still suck these guys.
What?!
Get out of here.
Nice.
All right, which five are we on this time?
What five is this?
What five is this, chat?
Okay, wait.
How do I...
How do I use the ult... Oh, my God.
I don't even remember.
5.6.
All right.
How do I use the...
Oh, my God.
Where's the book?
Play instruction.
How do I use the demon?
I'm using demon mode.
Dude.
Okay, LT and RT.
Five deluxe.
This is it.
I cannot be... I... I can't.
Oh, wait.
I did it.
Fuck this.
Wait, wait.
Give me my demon mode.
No!
I need my demon mode!
You fucker!
No!
Please!
It's not fair!
I need this!
Please!
It was worth it.
It was so worth it.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
This is fine.
It's worth it.
All right.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
I did it!
I got a purple necklace!
And then I got medicine.
Wow!
I got medicine!
Like, the ones I just...
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
What the fuck is the purple necklace for?
Reduces the amount of magic required.
Okay, that's good.
Actually, we actually need that.
Oh, my God.
Actually, that's actually good.
That's actually good.
What comes after five?
Yes.
Let me out.
Let me out of here.
All right.
We're out.
How do we get this, anyway?
Sealed.
See?
Just five floors.
I was gonna say, I was like, am I counting wrong?
Can I just cat count?
I was like, I think I went past five.
I'm pretty sure.
Am I counting wrong?
Can I just cat count?
I was like, this feels like I'm past five.
I was like, no.
No way.
That's it.
I cannot be bothered right now.
Okay, nice.
Oh, my God.
That's HP.
Okay.
Cherry Blossom Key.
Where is...
Oh, wait.
We had to...
Whoa!
Wait!
Where did this guy come from?
Okay, I was gonna say.
Where did he come from?
He, like, teleports by...
Whoa, shit!
Oh, my God.
They just keep teleporting behind me.
I literally cannot deal with these guys.
Like, I have to use magic against them.
I'm like, I cannot.
I cannot.
These guys are actually terrible.
Okay!
You can't jump all of them!
All right, I need to find the Crescent Moon for that.
Oh!
Back on the sword, because it's my only maxed out...
It's my only maxed out attack as equipment.
Oh, I'm back here!
Where'd I go?
Back here.
This is, like...
Okay.
I really need to...
I need to find, like, a...
A save point, though.
Like, I really need a save point.
Okay.
One by one.
I'm patient enough.
Jesus.
Okay.
That's five.
One by one.
Single file, everybody.
Okay, let's...
I just better not be an infinite spawn!
They don't...
Yeah, I was gonna say...
I swear to God!
I ain't here to be an infinite spawn right now!
It's just...
Guys, it's just five enemies, guys.
Toki, it's just five.
Don't know what you're worried about.
Oh, there he comes!
Another one!
I...
Okay.
I don't know how that guy got me.
Out of here.
Get out of here.
Oh, my God!
I think it loops.
Alright.
I don't know.
Now I actually do think it loops.
Alright, I have a feeling it might be endless.
I don't know.
Alright, I swear to God, if another one TP's in...
I...
Okay, we fucking broke the loop.
We broke the loop, guys!
We did it!
We broke the loop!
Oh, my God!
That's right!
All your friends are...
You thought you could keep floating yourself!
That's right!
We broke the cycle!
Okay, I'm leaving.
I need to save my game.
Wait, I...
I legitimately forgot how to suck.
Oh, it's...
I was like, what button is it again?
I pressed every button but the right one.
Whoa, shit!
Okay, I legitimately cannot be bothered with these guys.
He's like, hey, guys!
What's going on?
What?
Hey, Jerry!
Come here, my coffee break!
Alright.
Okay, now I can go through this door.
Still need an amulet for that.
Okay, got the crescent key.
Okay, so I just need to backtrack.
Humans as food.
I like that.
Creating the best ingredients has been a long, painstaking mission to mine for many years.
However, I've never found a perfect way to remove the innate cruelty of human beings.
It will allow several thousands of humans to roam in free space.
They'll eventually start killing each other.
Not over food, mind you.
But over territory.
What an incorrigible spirit species.
This makes it difficult to raise humans in a small area.
What is most difficult, though, is having to eliminate the human leaders of these fights in order to preserve our stock of humans.
And now, it's come to my attention that some demons believe that free-range humans are better than the cultivated ones.
Oh my god, they're creating human farms!
I mean, just...
Just farm children.
I think that's the easiest way.
Just make sure...
The moment they hit a teenage...
The moment they're teenagers, just eat them.
I mean, that's what nev...
Oh, wait.
Wait, that's the story of nev...
What was it called?
Never...
I forgot what...
You know that...
That...
That anime that was so good, and then it fell off hard in the second season?
Because it got so bad?
Yeah, just do what Promise Neverland did.
Just farm children.
It's that easy.
Until one of the child starts thinking...
Having too much free will.
Oh, farm the stupid ones!
As soon as they get...
As soon as you realize they get too smart, eat them.
Don't do what they did.
They made a mistake.
They were cultivating smart orphans.
They should...
That was their mistake.
Just make them...
Just make them dumb.
And the moment they start being too smart, just eat them.
What does the smart ones take...
They're not eating their brains!
This is me!
These are Japanese demons!
They're eating...
They're not eating brains!
They're not zombies!
I can't...
They're just eating me!
Meat is me!
Do you eat smarter cows?
No!
You eat the cows that are eating better grass!
I can tell the difference just by holding the knife when I prepare the human body.
I must admit that I found a difference in the firmness of the humans who roam free as opposed to the ones who raise our cells.
Yeah!
Free range!
Just put them...
Put these humans in an open field!
Yeah, we eat cows that are pampered and spoiled!
Not cows that are smart!
The best humans I've ever tasted would happen to be Tyra no Masakado.
This human broke his contract with the demons and, therefore, Asuna was soon set on the table for foreign brothers to feast upon.
I heard that Masakado had killed so many humans.
His name had been recorded in a history book.
Maybe there is a connection between the quality of the human flesh and their personality.
I don't know.
The theory merits further research.
Human Wagyu!
Yeah, just make sure they...
The...
What was it called?
The free...
Like, free range chickenings?
As long as we don't keep them in a cage!
They taste good enough.
Oh my god, it's a bigger puzzle.
Oh my god, I did it!
Why was this one so easy?!
Alright, number 12.
Alright.
Wait, you hated this puzzle?!
That one was literally the easiest one!
The less moves it has, the easier it is.
It's just because it has less moves.
Alright, let's go back.
Not fighting that.
Fuck that shit.
Oh my god, I'm leaving.
Fuck that.
That's way too many.
I'm already almost full HP.
Alright, let's get rid of him.
Okay, wait.
Thank you for waiting.
I like that he actually waited.
I really appreciate that.
I was like, wait.
He's like, okay.
Oh shit.
Alright, nice.
What?!
They can spit gas!
Okay, when were they able to spit gas?
Are you serious?
Get over here!
Get your ass over here!
Alright.
You're actually a waste of my resources.
Jesus Christ.
I'm so sad.
He actually, like, wasted my heals there.
There has to be one more, right?
No.
Oh, shit!
Oh, he missed.
Stupid.
Nice.
Alright, we got the crescent key.
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god.
They jump scared me.
I was not...
I was not expecting that.
This?
Nice.
Oh.
Okay.
I am in this room that has nothing.
What is this room for?
I have a gourd.
Okay, nothing else.
Does he not do anything?
What do you do?
Sir!
What is this room for?
What is the gourd for?
Wait, what?
Oh, is it equipment?
No.
Wait, where the fuck is it?
It's not in my equipment.
I swear to god.
It's a fucking gift.
I...
I'm not even gonna see him.
Like, when will I see him?
I can't believe it.
Like, I haven't seen him once because I fucking couldn't do that mission.
Oh, left side of the room to go in deeper?
Wait, there's a little end...
Wait, there is.
Wait, there's something behind.
He missed.
Haha.
Oh!
Oh my god, it's...
Alright.
Time to go into the special hole.
Oh, oh, nice.
Oh, thank god.
I got a little worried about my special hole.
Alright.
We'll upgrade this.
I got a little worried there.
That it might be dangerous in my special hole.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, where is the...
What is this area?
Oh, medicine!
Nice.
This person...
Is supposed to have done this...
To everyone who tried to get away.
Oh, what's in here?
What?
Wait, I can't even get past him.
What's the point?
I can't...
No!
He's blocked me!
I can't believe it!
I can't just walk to the side!
Wait, can I kill him?
Body block.
Oh, I can't.
That ash...
Okay, there's the other way.
Thank god.
I was gonna say, like...
What?
Like, they blocked...
Like, what was the point of being here?
They're just gonna block the entrance.
There's another hole.
There's another special hole.
What do I get out of this?
You know what they say?
There's always more than one special hole.
Oh, hey.
I'll just use magic first.
Oh, I don't want magic!
I was, like, spamming it.
I was like, hmm, why isn't it working?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Get rid of this guy first.
Alright.
Are you serious?
Okay, nice.
Gotta make sure I get that first.
No!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he tried to do a kick.
Oh my god, I hate these guys so much.
I fucking hate these guys so much!
Okay.
At least it gave me a little bit of HP, thank god.
I hate that it, like, randomly locks, so I can't do, like, the finishing blow.
Like, like, what the fuck is this bullshit?!
I can't do this bullshit.
Okay.
Fuck this.
I can't be bothered.
Actually, cannot be bothered.
I know I have time.
I know I have time!
To do an extra suck!
I feel like there's a boss battle right here.
I don't know.
It just, it just feels so boss battle-y.
Okay, I'm just gonna get rid of this guy first, before I do anything.
What?!
That's fine.
That's not fine.
Never mind!
I don't feel as fine no more!
Wait, I have one more.
Where am I?
I have one more for this.
That's good.
Go!
There we go.
Okay.
Where do I go?
There's something here.
I wanna go over here first.
Alright, never mind.
That was just a dead end.
Cool.
I just got lazy.
Alright, nice.
No, there's a dead end.
See?
Look.
Nothing here.
A wall!
What's over there?
That is weird, because it's just a random indent in the wall.
Oh no.
He's slowly walking up to me.
Okay.
I should have enough.
Yes.
Like, I cannot be bothered to kill these guys normally.
These guys are way too annoying to be killed normally.
Alright, get out of here.
Okay.
Get out!
Get out of here!
You mean nothing to me!
You're just easy fodder!
To pat the game time!
That's right, I said it!
You're just game time patters!
You're no challenge!
You're just going...
You're just here to be a little bit annoying!
Alright, where am I?
Am I supposed to like...
Oh my god, not you!
Not you!
God, I hate these guys so much.
Nice, okay.
Let me get rid of him first.
Alright.
It's nice that I can just use my magic for it.
And not to worry too much.
Get out of here!
Oh my god, please.
Please, open your eyes.
Wear glasses or something!
Please, it was right there!
How could I miss?
Alright.
Down the bridge I go.
Yay!
Wait, what?
What's up on the other side?
Oh my god.
Here to pad more of my time.
Oh, thank god.
You didn't auto-lock to the other guy.
Oh my god.
It's a Christmas miracle.
You're lucky I need XP.
Oh my god.
Get over here.
I heard you.
Give me my XP.
That's right.
You thought I wouldn't walk back?
Wait.
I'm here.
What?
Oh no.
This is a new area.
I was gonna say, like...
Was I just here?
Everything just looks the same.
Alright, Max does this.
Does she know she takes this damage?
I do.
But, like...
As long as I don't get hit, it should be fine.
Like...
We're going with the just don't get hit strat.
The petrification bullet that Guildenstern created is an absolute astounding weapon.
Anyone who is hit by this bullet becomes frozen like a stone statue, and they can easily be crushed into pieces and scattered, or that they can be displayed like a nice ornament.
As a precaution, Guildenstern created the Great Powder to counteract a bullet's effect, which she stored inside a bamboo too.
There's nothing to interfere with a weapon this magnificent.
Now, to start mass production.
Wait, that doesn't sound very...
Very nice.
Wait a minute.
Oh, it's a demon cave.
That sounds right.
How the fuck do I open that box?
Don't worry.
I'll never get hit.
I have magic by my side.
Whoa!
Ha-ha!
Told you.
Didn't get hit.
Jesus fucking Christ, not these guys again.
Get out of here!
It punched me!
I'm done.
Okay, that doesn't count, guys.
That doesn't count.
That...
That was absolutely bullshit.
I...
I don't count those.
We don't count those.
We don't count...
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God!
Where the fuck is this?
I like how I say that, and then I just get hit by...
Everything that could hit me just hit me there.
Like...
That's crazy.
Like, legitimately everything that hit me.
How, like, unlucky am I?
I don't get karma'd like that.
The fear!
All right, that's fine, we're still very much alive.
We're almost, we almost looped the looped back.
Oh, that looks like a boss fight.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Okay, that was a boss fight.
Whoa.
I was like, hey, that looks very dick.
That looks like people will be there.
Who would have, who would have thought there were people there?
I'll help you.
What?!
That, bro!
Oh, now you'll help me.
Oh my, thanks, girl.
Thanks.
I really appreciate the help.
I really appreciate that.
Thanks for the help.
Wow.
Great help.
Thanks, girl.
It was, it was so helpful.
Oh, so very helpful.
You better be behind me when I, oh, there she, she's gone.
She's gone.
As she's, she's already gone.
Truly, the most helpful.
Appreciate it.
Oh my, what could I have done without her?
Honestly.
What?
Oh my god.
What would I do without that woman?
Fuck this.
I'm done.
I'm so done.
Okay.
Get over here.
Alright, now this looks like a boss fight.
Oh, I got an herb.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Another box.
Okay.
We got this.
You've been training your whole life for this moment.
Okay, now this is a little more difficult.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Now it's five.
Oh my god.
It's more than three.
Guys, this is more than three.
Oh, no.
Not again.
No.
I thought I was freed.
Why?
Okay.
Not again.
When will this end?
I made nothing.
Wait, I remember.
Wait.
No, this is exactly what you're right.
How did I do it last time?
How did...
How did I...
I didn't think I have to come back to it, guys.
I didn't think I have to come back.
Johnny again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't think we'd come back.
He'll do it again eventually.
I thought it was over.
Nobody told me it never ended.
I was like this.
And then... Then what did I do?
What did I do?
I don't fucking remember.
I don't remember.
It was like this.
And then what did I do?
How did I do this?
I don't know.
I don't... Oh
my god.
What the fuck?
I don't... How did I get you up there?
Oh my god.
Is that at least... Okay.
Just tell me this.
Is the first move at least correct?
Like that's like... I don't ask for much.
Just the little things.
I just... Is the first move at least correct?
Like that's like...
No!
Okay.
Then maybe it's like this.
And then I recreated that... I recreated that moment.
I recreated it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This has to be the first move then.
Oh my god.
I did it again.
Why do I keep making it?
Why do...
Why do I keep making that move?
Okay.
Alright.
This is the correct move.
And then I did it again.
I keep doing the same thing.
It just looks so right.
Why?
I can't help it.
It looks so correct.
Then what?
Oh my god.
I did it again.
I never learned.
I keep doing it.
I keep doing this.
I keep... I keep doing it.
I just don't learn.
Oh my god.
I did it.
I finally broke the cycle.
Guys, I broke the cycle.
I finally did it.
I broke the cycle and I did a new move.
Wait.
That's it?
There was nothing else here?
What?
Oh wait.
I could have just used this.
What the fuck?
Why am I doing?
Oh my god.
I didn't even realize I could have just used that.
Oh!
Wait.
I needed the grape powder?
Oh!
I forgot about the grape powder.
Where is it?
But where am I supposed to give that to?
Oh!
I can save them!
Don't worry, sir.
I'm a hero.
I got you, bro!
Boom.
You're here.
Oh, by the way, I found these before.
Yay!
Oh!
I can get free stuff!
I'm a hero!
Oh my god.
I keep pressing cancel.
Alright.
Wait.
You don't have anything for me?
What's the point of saving you?
Wait.
If you don't have items, why would I save you?
To be a good person?
Okay.
But like...
I only be a... I'm only a good person if I get something.
End game.
Why...
I am a hero for hire.
Oh, whoa.
Doki.
I'm forced to work here.
And this place gives me the creeps.
And the skin on my hands peeled off.
And so I can hold my...
Some weird monkey-like man told me I'd outlive my usefulness.
And before I knew it, everything went dark.
I don't remember anything after that.
Guys, I'm a bounty hunter.
Of course I...
Do good things for pay.
Okay.
I found something really nice today.
I found something really nice, but like...
I'm on my side today.
I was gonna use this later, but my partner would just get angry.
So I'll give it to you.
Don't tell them, okay?
Oh, yay!
Medicine!
Okay, nice.
All of them?
Is there any more over here?
I don't remember if there's any of...
Like...
Stone guys here.
No.
Okay, let's leave.
Alright, that should be all of them.
Okay.
Oh, they all left too.
Wait, there's one more?
Where's the last guy?
He's at the middle of the map?!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Like, do I...
Should I go like...
Behind?
From the behind?
Or should I just...
Run this way?
Where is he?
Do I go like...
Where I'm going right now?
Is it closer?
Is where I'm going closer, chat?
Okay, good.
See, this is why I need back seaters.
Okay.
Get out of here.
You guys are all useless.
Oh my god.
Guarded in time.
I was worried that it was going to hit me there.
Very slowly.
Suck that up.
Yeah, I saved.
Don't worry.
That was the first thing I did.
I made sure of it.
Okay.
Where is the last guy?
Is he here?
Where is he?
I'm gonna use the sword.
Oh, after this room?
Okay.
I'll just grab some XP then.
I'll just...
Kill the...
Kill the enemies that hear the pad time.
Get over here.
Your purpose is to give me XP!
That's right.
That is your purpose.
Okay, not you though.
Okay, you're actually scary.
You actually have worth.
Uh, nah.
Not worth it.
Wait, where is he?
Wait, did you guys lie?
Where is he?
Is he like...
All over here?
Where the fuck is this guy?
Oh, after this bridge?
I swear to god.
If this is like the...
Plus five shit again.
I swear to fucking god.
I...
I'm this close.
I'm this close, guys.
I'm like, okay.
You guys are...
You're so lucky.
You're so lucky you're actually here.
I tried to escape.
I couldn't even move.
I almost wet my pants.
It's a good thing I didn't.
Or this thing I put in my pocket would have been soaked.
But it's not.
If it's not, so I'll give it to you.
There's a lot I could do in return.
Oh my god, it's just okay.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Alright.
I'll go the other way back.
I don't...
I'm scared I have to fight the big guys.
Alright, at least it's not soggy medicine.
Thank fucking god.
Hey, we're just gonna run past all of them.
I cannot be bothered.
They're like...
They gave me too little XP to actually make it worth fighting.
If they were like the strong guys, then I'm fine with it.
Okay.
Are you...
Oh my god.
I was...
I don't have enough magic too.
Fuck.
Okay.
It's fine.
I can run past all of them.
I'm so sad.
I accidentally used up two of my magic attacks there.
Cause I got...
I was trying...
I forgot I always had my sword with me.
I thought I had...
The win.
Okay, they're like...
It's like fighting a level five Zubat.
I...
It's not worth it.
It's not worth my time.
To fight a level five Zubat for like five XP, guys.
Alright.
You think he's made of stone?
Oh, nevermind.
Yeah, I'll use my sword here.
I mean, he is made of stone, but you know what I mean.
What do I do here?
What shit!
Oh my god.
I fucking hate you.
I hate you.
I hate you!
Okay.
That's time to suck here.
Nice.
Got the suck just in time.
Okay.
Uh...
Am I supposed to...
Here?
Oh!
What the fuck?
He like just jumped out of nowhere!
Oh.
Goodbye.
Let me share.
Wait.
There's like...
Something...
Oh.
Alright.
These guys are worth farming though.
They actually give me lots of XP.
So I'll...
I'll farm them.
They're not like the lizard people.
Lizards just lay too many eggs.
So they're like...
Their value lowers down.
There's just too many.
You know?
Supply and demand.
That's fine.
I want them to respawn.
Okay.
No!
Why did you get it away?!
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
That was meant for him.
You fucker actually got in the way.
I had to waste the magic on you!
Oh my god.
And then he got up.
Oh nice.
Souls.
Suck.
Alright.
We gotta go...
This way.
Oh.
Crits yield more souls?
That's so cool.
I wonder how you can crit.
Oh my god.
Man.
The only issue is that...
I don't know how to crit, guys.
If only...
If only I could crit so I could do just like...
Just that.
Because...
That's the one thing that may or may not be stopping me with that.
How...
How do I open those boxes?
Am I like...
Do I...
I still don't have the item, right?
To get those boxes?
I just wanna be sure.
I wanna be sure.
Oh, it's a different character.
Oh my god.
Than it is.
Backtrack.
March 1573.
Human calendar.
Those who enter will receive 500 human bodies.
As a special bonus.
Oh my god.
Oh, I gotta quit my day job.
How do I apply?
500 human bodies?
That's so many humans.
The schedule is subject to change based upon the performance of the Takeda Hunt.
What a bonus!
What the fuck?
How do I apply?
I...
Oh my god.
This is a fucker.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Of course!
Of course I auto-lock into you.
You worthless fucking lizard man.
The only reason there's so many...
You're like a fucking Zergling.
Oh my god.
That's it.
I'm bringing in that tornado.
Indi...
Individual wise, you're not special.
Your only worth is that there's so many of you.
Alright.
I wonder if I can kill him.
No, I can't.
Alright, I gotta use one more magic.
Yeah, too many clearly.
Got practice.
Clearly we...
We need sex ed for these lizard people.
Although Lord Nobunaga was killed in Okehazama.
He rose from the dead by the power of the demons.
With the help of Fortinabras, Nobunaga tried to exterminate the Saito clan of Minno province.
But the only warrior...
Oh, are they like the...
Are they like the lesbian lizards?
Where they...
They're all female.
They just like...
Reproduce and clone themselves.
Stop this evil plan.
When the king of the demons, Fortinabras, met his ultimate fate at Inabayama castle.
Nobunaga's evil ambition also came to an end.
No one could imagine that Fortinabras would be defeated.
It was the worst crisis the demons ever faced.
But it's Nobunaga who saved them.
Although he was originally a human, Fortinabras saw his potential.
And soon...
Nobunaga created order from the chaos and became the king of the demons.
He destroyed the Saito clan of Minno province.
And is now ready to conquer the entire world.
Okay, but what about like American demons?
Would American demons let him do that?
Like...
Cause he's like...
It's like...
You know how like...
It's like zombie apocalypse that only happens in like...
America or London?
And everybody just looks around and be like...
Are they okay, guys?
So today...
The golden evil statue is complete.
The statue is made out of roughly 6,000 tons of gold.
When I first saw Guildenstern's design specification, I could not fathom why Lord Nobunaga wanted the statue.
But now it's complete.
I can understand and am confident that the statue shines with a dignity that entites humans to worship it.
Humans love nothing more than to idolize them, those they consider above themselves.
While Fortinabras tried to rule humans for force, Nobunaga, being human himself, understand how the little maggots think and what their weaknesses are.
Under his rule, we have enjoyed many ceremonies and sacrifices.
The statue will allow us to feast upon even more delicious flesh.
Lord Nobunaga is a genius!
Is that really all it takes?
Like one fucking shiny statue?
Sorry.
One fucking shiny golden evil statue.
Like that's all it takes.
Humans are such simple creatures.
As long as it's gold and evil.
Thank you very much, sir.
I never expect to be saved.
Can I freeze up?
Oh, no?
Okay.
Okay, I guess.
Okay, now this is a little harder.
I think?
No.
Okay, never mind.
It's just literally checkers.
Like...
Never mind.
It's just...
It's just checkers.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
A blood pond.
Where did they get all this blood from?
Oh.
Special magic liquid.
I don't know.
Feels awfully bossy of it.
Oh.
This feels like an actual boss fight now.
Maybe I shouldn't have used my magic there.
Oh well.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
I was in the middle of my fucking magic attack.
Okay.
That's fucked up.
He interrupted my magic.
Now I'm mad.
Interrupted my flow.
My groove.
Okay.
I need to find something here.
Never interrupt...
Jubei.
I had to remember his name.
Nobody said his name anymore for the longest time.
I was like...
What was his name again?
Literally no one said his name for so long.
I got confused.
I was like...
What was your name again, bro?
Oh my god.
There's three of them.
And I don't have enough magic power.
Okay.
That's fine.
I still have hammer.
Hammer!
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I can't see.
Hammer still!
Oh my god.
I still had hammer.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh shit!
That's fine.
There we go.
Oh, and I got mushroom.
Jesus Christ.
Why are you...
Oh my god.
I was gonna say.
My depth perception.
I was like, where are you?
Smash!
Okay, this way.
This way?
Yeah, this way.
Okay, maybe there's something over here.
Whoa.
Whoa, he seems a little scary, guys.
Hammer?
Hahaha!
Okay, that's fine.
I have magic!
Nice.
I was a little worried there.
I was like, hammer time?
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
I was like, what am I jumping for?
Jesus.
Okay.
Okay, I got this, guys.
Oh my god.
I fucked up.
Wait, wait.
I actually got this.
Okay, wait, wait.
Wait, I actually got this.
Wait.
Ah, see?
See?
I told you.
I told...
I knew it.
I told you.
Guys, I told you.
I told you I got this.
Oh, we're my non-believers.
That's right.
Show yourself my non-believers.
That's...
I saw you guys.
You guys didn't believe.
I knew it.
Aw, man.
All those non-believers out there.
The doubters.
All my doubters.
Look at me now.
That's right.
This is who you doubted in high school.
Should be almost dead, yeah.
I know it's like the magic makes them like almost dead.
That's right.
That fucking low up.
That's the kid you doubted in high school.
Look at her now.
She solved that puzzle.
And she didn't cry.
She didn't cry this time.
Oh, nice.
The scarlet key.
Which key was that?
Wait, can I take these?
I should be allowed to take it.
Oh, I'm here?
Where?
Where the fuck do I go now?
It's back here?
I'll kill you for XP, actually.
Might be good XP farm.
Oh yeah, definitely.
Yeah, I need this for XP.
Okay, I'll save for that.
Okay, and then...
Enhance.
That's right, enhance.
Okay, down here.
That has to be for the statue now, right?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Okay, that actually got me.
He actually got me.
I was not expecting it.
That's right, got range!
That's right!
Suck!
Bullshit!
Oh my god!
That's right, you missed!
What are the mushrooms for?
I've got so many of them.
Wait, they're not even in my inventory.
What?
I swear to god, are they gifts?
Of course they are.
I can't even give it to them!
I have no friends!
I
got greedy!
All
my friends were like, bros.
Ever since you got with her, we like never hang out now.
So like, I don't know.
No!
Never choose the host before the bros!
Not here?
What was the door with the two eyes?
Guys!
Oh, the robot!
Oh my god, I don't remember.
It's been 20 years, guys.
I cannot remember.
It's not us, bro.
It's you.
That's the reason why we don't hang out anymore.
See?
They're so nice.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?!
Where are the robots?!
What?!
Oh my god!
Oh
my god!
I'm so lost!
I'm actually so lost!
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die to the bozeman!
Oh my god, I'm actually gonna die to the bozeman!
I...
...I can't get there.
I can't get there!
Oh my god, I'm just dying to the bozeman!
Oh my god, okay, I have to use that though.
If I didn't, I actually would have died.
Holy fuck.
I'm so mad.
They're like, there's a robot.
There's a robot you were asking about earlier.
And I'm like, not like that.
That's not what I mean and you know it.
I don't think I would have had enough time to use my gun.
I don't think so.
That's why I didn't use it.
Oh, it's the evil human.
Oh, there you are.
Couldn't do that?
Bro, you were so strong.
You couldn't just push him?
Oh, no.
Whoa!
Okay, she better help me now.
Yeah, I'm like, why is she so helpless?
Not like she was fighting fucking demons earlier.
Like, how are you helpless now?
That guy had like, no muscle.
What am I...
What do I do?
What the fuck do I do down here?
What is it?
Yeah.
Bro,
I love this game.
It's so campy.
It's so fucking weird.
It's like, so different from one.
One that was like, so serious.
But here they're like, let's just add...
I don't know.
Let's just add fucking robots or some shit.
I was like...
Yeah.
Like, what was like about demons?
And...
Like, demon lore?
And they're like, I don't fucking know.
Robots.
I don't know.
Who's Hoichi?
Oh!
Yeah!
That's her?
This guy has like, a fucking Wikipedia about her.
Like, holy shit!
Once...
I became a member of the Asai family.
I thought I should stop my brother.
So I went to Gifu castle and tried to take his life.
That's when I met you.
Yeah?
And she's like, why do I try to do all the work when he's there?
Me?
Points at myself?
That's right, Nobunaga.
I'm gonna bang your sister.
The greatest revenge.
You killed my entire family?
I...
Fuck your sister.
Yeah!
The wildest wildest.
And then I'm gonna marry her and take your children.
And then your daughters are gonna call me dad.
Sorry, your nieces.
Then your nieces will call me dad.
I forgot.
I was like, wait, no.
That's the brother.
They're not like me.
That's right, Nobunaga.
You see this?
That's... Oh, shit!
That's right!
Nobunaga's like, no, not my sister!
No!
Nobunaga's like, wait, wait, stop!
That's my sister!
Stop!
Not my sister!
You fucking... you fucking whore!
Ha ha ha ha!
How dare you!
You hurt us.
You fucking hurt us.
Don't you, Nehra!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, no, you don't!
NTR, don't you... It's not NTR!
It's the brother!
It's...
It's her brother, guys!
We're not playing that...
What the fuck?
That...
That incest game.
I forgot.
Some...
Something something family or whatever that game is.
Golgantus, he is the greatest swordsman of all the demons.
He moves gracefully like a dancer.
He's strong like a storm.
He has conjured a barrier like a steel wall around himself.
Which today has yet to be broken.
Yeah, Andy and Lele...
This is not an...
Copy of Andy and Lele, guys!
Only the sacred flute has a chance to defeat his incredible barrier.
Uh...
And only a swordsman who has the blood of the only can play his flute.
Oh shit, is that Mr. Nimbus?
Don't worry, I have the power of the flute, Mr. Nimbus!
Oh shit.
Oh my god, Nobunaga does not want me to kiss his sister.
Wait, I thought he was the enemy.
What?
What the fuck?
Are you alright?
You don't have to be thankful.
It is quite natural for men to save.
Okay.
She's like...
Yeah.
That's me.
I'm so weak.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
That's it?
This is the battle that I've been waiting for.
The...
My name is Gougandantus.
The greatest swordsman of all demons.
Whatever.
You say that...
Alright, skip.
Do you face like...
My name is Gougandantus, Benz.
Didn't you say that?
Can we get on with this?
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
I'm all yours.
Didn't we just say that?
Angar!
Okay.
Don't worry.
I shall play my magical flute.
That's right.
I got you now.
Don't do anything yet.
I'm playing my flute.
He's like...
No!
The power of music!
Not music!
No!
Okay.
Nice.
I don't think...
No, I don't think he is.
What?
What the fuck?
Okay, wait.
Don't worry.
I have this.
That's fucking right.
I have...
Whoa!
Wait!
I still have this.
That's right.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
I still have this!
Okay.
And then...
Hammer time!
Oh, shit!
Do you think I hit him?
Do you think...
Oh, no.
That's okay.
I got this, too.
That's right!
Wait.
How far...
No, I'm not.
It's okay.
I can go back.
I didn't think he was gonna hit me there.
Okay, guys.
Alright.
What's my last autosave?
Wait.
Where am I?
Oh!
Okay, it's not that far.
Okay.
Hi!
It's okay.
That's...
That's fine.
I got a little worried.
I...
It's just before the cutscene.
Thank God.
I was like...
Wait.
I feel like I'm in such a far place.
But it's where...
Why the fuck is the autosave here?
Okay.
That's stupid.
No, I got a little worried.
I was like...
Oh my God.
I swear to God.
If it like takes me to...
20 years ago.
I...
Okay.
I won't be as cocky this time.
I swear.
I swear to God.
I got...
I just play my magical flute.
Okay.
Magic power of music by my side.
Let's go.
That's right.
Music time.
The power of Grayskull.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh fuck.
I thought I had more.
Okay.
Maybe...
Alright.
Just to be safe.
Let me use my medicine.
Hammer!
I don't care.
Nice.
There you go.
I had...
Just to be safe situation.
Oh.
Now I care.
I was the one that killed him.
You've become so strong.
Great Assurge in my ass.
He just had a barrier.
Look at...
Look at that.
This is what happens if you commit all to defense guys.
See?
What did defense do for him?
Say my name.
I did that!
What is my name again?
Oh my god.
The greatest swordsman of all the demons.
The greatest swordsman.
That's all I wanted, Jufay.
All I wanted was you to say my name.
Oh my god.
I did it.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
That's a lot.
That's all.
That's all he wanted.
From Jubei.
I gave him his final wish.
Your respect.
Is it here?
Yeah.
I will name my kid after you, Gogodontas.
And then all the villagers will be like, What the fuck?
Isn't that that demon that slayed thousands of people?
And I'll be like, he was the greatest...
He was...
He was the greatest swordsman.
Wait, there was like a chest here.
It's like...
It's like that one scene.
What was it?
In like, Harry Potter or some shit?
Where like, he named his kids after like, fucking...
Evil people.
People are like, no, but he redeemed himself.
He's not evil no more.
It's different.
Oh, whoa, that hurts me.
And they're terrible names too, by the way.
Those are some fucking terrible names.
Oh, Zekra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Salute to the greatest swordsman of all the demons.
Alright.
Let's go.
Goodbye.
Gogodontas.
One last puzzle for the ride.
Christ.
He was truly the greatest, guys.
The greatest demon.
Out there.
What?
Okay, I got one side.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
What about the other side?
Oh, okay.
I'm just stupid.
Okay, I got it.
There we go.
I keep missing one step.
Yay!
I was just missing one step of it.
Look at that.
Look at that, guys.
That's right.
This is who you made fun of in high school.
Look at her now.
Look at her now!
Say her name!
What's my name?
Is that a song?
Say my name.
That was a song.
I know it.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, there she is.
I'm glad you're safe.
We should get out of here immediately.
What song was it?
Oh, I have the orb.
Yes.
Oh, I got the...
Oh, and he has the...
Of course.
Of course he has the respect orb.
Her name is Doki, the greatest swordsman of the birds.
Alright, what robot's gonna come out this time?
What is this robot?
What the fuck is that?
Is that turtle?
What's this battle mech that I have?
My Bakugan.
Battleship?
Hey, wait!
Holy shit, what the fuck?
It's actually a battleship.
Oh my god, is that a fucking submarine?
Who built this?
Like...
And it flies?
Bro, what?
It flies?
Eyes?
Who the fuck built this?
Is this some alien shit?
Oh, there's another battleship.
Battleship Junior.
No, I don't...
I don't...
The craziest part is that I actually don't remember anything about the second game.
I remember watching my dad play it.
But for some fucking reason, I did not retain any of the... of this.
Whatever the fuck this was.
Yeah, you think I remember this.
The fucking robot horse.
Mecha fish.
And then...
The flying turtle mech.
I must get this door open.
I'll help you.
Oh no.
This is timed.
OH NO!
Time puzzles!
I'll try the left handle in the opposite direction.
Let's go.
Wait, I thought you were gonna...
What do you mean?
Oh my god, you're not... I have to beat both of you?
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is so stupid.
I have to beat both of them.
I thought, you know... I thought the NPC would help me.
But I was wrong.
Please.
Please, we're almost there.
Are you...
Are you sure?
Yes, I'm sure.
What do you mean?
Are you gonna make the puzzle easier for me?
Are you just gonna make this puzzle easier?
Like... I fucked up one puzzle.
Okay.
Okay, I fucked up one puzzle.
Just the one puzzle.
What?
How are they gonna make it easy?
Like, I just don't have to do a puzzle anymore.
Like...
I don't know.
I... She was like, I'll turn the left one.
You turn the right.
So I assume...
I'll try the left hand.
Like, you know, she says, I'll do it.
So, obviously, like, you think, like, the NPC will do it for you, you know?
Like, it just sounded like the NPC was actually gonna help me there.
But silly me for thinking that!
She's... Like, I don't know.
I didn't think I'd control both.
Oh my god, please.
I'm trying my best here.
There we go.
Never trust the NPC.
Okay.
Such a difficult puzzle.
Are you sure you don't want to do this puzzle in easy mode?
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
I can't believe he asked me.
Oh my god, I'm like, the right brothers.
What the fuck was that sound?
What?
Don't worry.
I won't let you die.
I still need to make Nobunaga angry.
That's why we don't have...
That's why, like...
Japan didn't invent the first flying machine.
Jubei fucked it up for all of us.
I still...
Yeah, I still need to get revenge.
Don't worry.
I need to, like, have him see.
I bring her closer to her brother so he can watch and see.
That's right.
The greatest revenge.
Okay, I need to make sure what's back here, though.
What is back here?
Okay, I knew it.
Oh, fuck.
God.
No, it's six.
No.
Oh, no.
My greatest weakness.
Six moves.
Oh, no.
No.
Not six moves.
Anything but that.
Oh, I did it.
Yeah!
Oh my god, I actually did it!
Holy fuck!
Oh my god, I'm so fucking smart!
I actually did it!
Oh my god, I actually did it!
No way!
I almost used it.
Oh my god, it's actually a Christmas miracle.
Okay, I need a save though.
I don't want- I don't remember how I did it.
I actually- I don't remember it.
We can't- we have to save.
Oh my god, get out of here.
Get out of here.
Oh my god!
Where are you?
Get out!
Alright, as long as he's out of the way.
Oh, nice medicine.
We gotta stockpile that.
Where am I?
How do I?
Over here.
What?
Where do- yeah.
Oh shit!
Yeah, I'm not fighting those.
I don't care.
Actually...
Okay.
Okay, if I line them up, it might be worth it.
Nice, I knew it.
See guys?
I figured it out.
Wait, there's one more.
Wait, there's more of them?
Okay, I figured it out though.
Oh, oh no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
I didn't expect to see all of these guys.
Okay, that's a lot of them.
Okay, um...
Oh, that is a lot more.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, that's a lot more than I expected.
Wait, there's more?!
Oh no!
Okay, that's enough.
I'm done.
I had my fun.
Wait, they spawned during pauses?!
Okay.
Yeah, I was like, you know what?
No, you know they can have this.
Well, the turbinus conveniently led me to the exit.
How lovely, how wonderful.
Oh, there you are.
Where the fuck were you?
You think I know how to drive?
I've never seen this either.
I don't think anybody in Japan knows how to fucking drive this.
You think I've seen a flying machine before?
Like...
Like, it's like, I don't know how to drive this.
Like, you think I know either?!
We both saw this for the first time!
I don't know how to drive, Lord Nobunaga will conquer the entire country!
You should just give up now!
Silence!
It is the first order of the Yagyu clan to stop all demons from the underworld.
Now, prepare yourself, Tokuchiro!
Wait, wait, if you really want this ship, I shall give it to you!
Wait, is that easy?
Oh!
Never mind, it wasn't that easy.
Enjoy your ride!
What?!
Does he fucking invent...
Oh!
What?!
What the fuck?!
Oh, that's a lot of demons!
Oh my god!
I was like, does he invent the fucking first ever parachute too?!
Like, what's happening?!
Oh, see, she knows how to drive.
Apparently it was that easy.
I must do something.
What?
Maybe check the instruments over here?
Here?
Did I do it?
We can attack with this.
Do you know what you're doing?
Yeah, I'm gonna say, do I know what I'm doing?
Just believe in the heart of the cards.
Just press any buttons.
Let's go, Jubei!
Just press...
What the fuck?!
See?
We did it!
Wait, that...
That actually worked!
It was just that easy.
Curse that Tokijiro!
Wait...
I like, I was like, I can't believe he would do this!
I say as I press all the buttons to activate self-destruct mode.
Must die.
It's his fault!
Not mine!
It's like that bicycle meme.
You can't die!
No!
My revenge!
I guess killing his sister is sort of like revenge, but it's not as cool.
It's not as good.
Can't believe it.
All she had to do was jump.
Bro, why can't you dump jump?
Is she stupid?
She unbinded her jump button.
Can't believe it.
I can't believe she forgot to bind her jump button.
Wait, who's that?
Is that the...
Oh, that's the drunk guy!
Wait, I have gourds!
I'm welcome!
Am I actually fighting him?
Are you serious?
If so, I will not.
Are you ready, Jumei?
Ready to face the master of the Halloween Spear?
Oh, my relationship was too low.
Okay!
Like, how?
Like, okay, all I'm saying, like...
It's not my fault I picked the wrong woman.
Look, I...
I fucked up!
Wait, what?
What?
Okay, it's not...
No, we're not doing a fair fight.
We're not...
I was like, you want to make this fair?
No, demon more time.
If I can't use my demon sword, I'll just use demon gun.
Don't say such things.
So anyway, I started blasting.
No!
All those gourds that I fucking found!
Please, I have the gourds!
Just take them!
Oh, he's crying.
Because I fucking killed him.
That looks like a penis.
He looks quite peaceful.
Is this the way you want it to go, Ike?
Okay, what did I get?
What is that?
This is also a gift?
Wait, where is it?
Where's the thing I stole from him?
Oh, there we go.
That's his chain!
Oh, shit.
Wait!
Can I...
Okay, I was gonna say, like...
I don't care about honor.
I need my magic.
It's magic time.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I was like, gift?
Yeah, gift.
That's right.
He gave it to me, guys.
Right...
He's told me to keep it, guys.
Right before he died.
I swear to God.
Oh, shit.
How did I do that?
Oh my god, the crit gives so much.
I wish I know how to do that consistently.
If only I know how to do that.
Alright, get out of here.
Nice.
Anything here?
Okay, wait.
Try this first.
Okay, yeah, no.
Get out of here.
Oh no, I don't think I have enough.
Fuck, okay.
Uh...
Oh no.
Alright.
Let me figure out how to use gun.
Oh.
Wait, is that easy?
Wait!
Wait, it was that easy?
Oh shit.
Should've used gun more.
That's it.
I just shoot it.
Oh my god, it's a 5 plus room again.
Just a stupid 5 plus area.
Okay.
Do I go up the ladder or do I go right side?
Or do I go out and go the other way?
Chat.
I don't have a map so I don't know.
Do I...
Up the ladder?
Okay.
What the fuck?
Am I shooting it?
Oh my god, I can't tell.
Like...
Are they getting shot?
I can't...
Ow!
Fucking no!
Oh my god.
Okay, I have enough for a tornado.
That's fine.
There we go.
Just enough.
Oh, thank god.
Very slowly.
Can my...
People hit him with the eyes?
Jesus Christ.
Thanks.
No!
Okay, fire arrow.
I hate them.
Oh my god, you fuckers.
I don't know.
I don't know!
That's it!
I'm mad now!
I'm mad!
I don't know how to kill him.
How do I kill him?
How is it sick?
Don't understand!
I have more.
Okay.
I missed two times and I had a popstick.
Oh my God, I'm shooting the fire!
Oh, it's getting closer!
Wait, it's fucking finally!
It's getting closer!
Thank God!
Get over here!
Jesus Christ!
Oh, I got it.
Thank God.
Okay, we got it.
We fucking got it.
I was like, am I hitting it?
Guys, I don't think I was hitting it.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, I have to go downstairs.
That's a classic.
I don't know.
I thought I was hitting it at first.
It looked like I was hitting it!
And I was like, guys, you think I'm hitting it?
Does it look like I'm hitting it, guys?
I can't tell.
Alright, it's time.
Okay.
I don't know what this is gonna do.
But it's time.
Is it worth it?
Chat, is it worth it to do this?
It's 20 floors!
Is it worth it, chat?
I need to know before I go down there.
I get a flame sword?
Okay, that sounds pretty badass.
Alright, it's time.
Yes.
Okay, that does sound pretty badass.
So I'll use this for now.
Okay,
I also needed the demon stuff, too, anyway.
That's good.
Oh!
Okay, I might not use my magic until I'm, like, way deep in there.
But it doesn't feel like it's worth it at this point.
Okay, I need that.
That's magic, though.
All you get is a t-shirt.
If you do the math, if you do this.
Are you serious?
I'm gonna get the sword, actually.
Alright.
Nice.
Down I go.
Okay, I just wanna kill him, though.
Nice.
Get out of here.
You serve no purpose but to die!
That's right!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, now I can use...
I'll use this.
Actually, I should use...
I should use this.
Just because there are so many of them.
Suck.
Okay, nice.
Oh, no.
There's more of you?
Alright.
Get out of here.
I have one more.
Oh, wait.
I don't.
I was gonna say, I have one more in me.
I actually don't.
Here we go.
Poke.
Hello?
Oh, okay.
I got a little worried.
I thought I got stuck here.
I was like, huh?
Alright, there we go.
That got a little worrisome there.
I thought I got stuck down there.
I was like, oh, that's bad.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
I didn't see him.
Actually...
You know what?
Hammer time.
There we go.
I feel like...
Yeah, hammers.
Oh.
That's right.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Get out!
Hammer!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Stop!
I said stop!
Okay, that's it.
I'm angry.
I'm angry now.
That's it.
You made me use wind.
You made me angry.
Oh, nice.
Wait, what the fuck?
That was so OP.
Holy fuck.
Oh, my God.
He was like, what the fuck?
Wait, you weren't supposed to kill him yet.
Oh, fuck.
You think Pothi's gonna save you?
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Shit!
He just picked me up.
Just like that.
I was like, let me go, please.
Get grappled.
I didn't think he would just pick me up like that.
Bro, that was scary.
That was scary.
He just like, picked me up like I was nothing.
Give me a sec.
Don't move yet.
Okay, nice.
I was like, can you just like, wait a little bit?
Oh, no.
I don't have any more magic.
Wait, I think this does one more extra.
No.
Okay, it's time to fight him legit now.
I have no more magic, guys.
I am not using my item.
Oh, my God.
I have to do it legit.
It felt terrible.
Oh, my God.
I have to play that legitly.
You legit fighting.
I know.
It felt disgusting.
Okay, I can spin for this.
I hate these guys.
I'm spinning for it.
I can't spin for it.
No!
What do you mean I can't spin?
What's the point?
Oh, my God.
I hate these guys.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
I hate you guys so much.
Because I can't lock you.
Okay.
I did not expect that.
I take those.
Nice.
Oh, I take those.
Hello?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, I would spin.
But they're all too far away to justify it.
They're too far.
Wait.
Spin!
Oh, my God.
I hate you.
I wish I could kill your entire family.
That's how much I hate you.
Oh, my God.
I can't spin.
I'm so sad.
This is actually, like, the perfect spin, cop.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, I got the spin!
Worth.
I can spin.
It was so worth it.
Alright.
We just wait.
Just gotta wait.
Get over here.
Alright.
Get over here!
That's right!
Stabby, stabby.
Oh, thank God.
Proceed.
Oh, no.
I think I have enough.
I think I have...
No!
What?
Are you serious?
No, I don't have enough!
No!
I, in fact, did not have enough, guys.
Guys, please.
Nice.
Okay.
I can't believe...
I blocked it, but it didn't register there.
I'm so mad.
I'm so...
Oh, I'm so mad.
I'm so mad.
That's it!
Just for you!
I spin just for you!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Get them out of here.
Get them out of here!
Oh, I have so little HP.
Guys, I don't even know what room I'm in anymore.
I...
I don't know.
I haven't been counting.
I'm so confused.
I'm so...
Oh, my God!
What number am I on?
Five...
5.3.
Okay, I might need a heal.
Like, this looks like a...
This looks like a healing situation.
Like...
I think I have to be desperate here.
Oh!
Okay.
I'm glad I healed.
I'm...
I'm glad...
I'm glad I...
I swear...
to God.
Of course it locks onto him.
Of fucking course it locks onto the lizard.
Of fucking course.
It locks to the one I didn't want to lock.
Okay.
I'm so scared.
No, I can live this.
Okay.
I can still live this, guys.
I don't think I can live this anymore.
I...
This was the moment I realized.
Maybe I don't live this.
Okay.
All right.
We did it.
I got a little worry there, guys.
That I might not live it.
Just a little bit.
It was only a little scary.
All right.
Nice.
We made it, though.
Oh my god.
These rooms feel like forever.
I feel like I've been trapped in purgatory for so long.
All for the stupid...
...flame.
Because the knife had fire.
Doki, you don't understand, Doki.
It's a flaming knife, Doki.
You don't understand.
It would be so cool.
Yeah.
But fire.
Good, Doki.
All right.
Okay.
Let's make sure I grab all of this.
Oh my god.
There's...
Okay.
I want to be sure, like, what I'm...
Get out of here!
Okay.
Oh, hammer time!
There we go.
There's more!
That's it!
I'm done!
You don't get magic!
I'm tired!
Yeah, I had enough.
I had enough.
No magic for you!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Maybe I should give him magic.
That's it.
That's too many.
Too many.
Now you get magic.
There's just too many things going on on my screen.
Oh, why?
Yeah, I know.
I was like, wait a minute.
All right.
I'm done.
I was like, that's...
That's it.
You've had your fun.
I'm done.
Okay.
Are you fucking giving me?
Get out of here.
Oh
my god!
Stop!
I will flatten you.
Stop.
I'm done.
Stop this.
Stop this!
Stop!
I'm not playing anymore.
Get out of here.
Get out!
I shall flatten you.
Not fucking around anymore.
Just stop.
No.
I was gonna say... Oh no.
Okay, I still have... I still have magic.
What?
Okay.
Okay, I was gonna swear.
I swear to God.
I was gonna... I was gonna be more angry.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, these guys... I swear to God.
Your existence doesn't matter!
Yeah, the hammer's strong.
But, like, the lead-up time for it is, like, too much.
Oh my god.
Why are you defending?
Why are you blocking?
I am... I'm not dying to these guys.
I... I... I'm not dying to them.
I'm not...
I'm not dying to these fuckers.
Okay.
Get out of here.
All right, here we go.
Another room.
Oh no, not that.
Oh no.
Okay, it's fine.
I have hammer.
Not these guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
Got a little worried about the...
Oh fuck!
I forgot they explode!
Oh shit!
Okay, that was my bad.
I forgot about the explosions.
That was my bad.
Okay.
I'm not getting close to that.
I'm not.
I learned my lesson.
Oh wait.
Oh, it's these guys.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
Okay, not nice.
All right, nice.
Oh god, please don't hit me.
Please don't hit me while I do this.
Please don't hit me!
Nice!
Oh, they got the perfect pairing.
The perfect counter.
I got scared.
Oh!
They got lucky there.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh!
Got the crit when it matted!
I don't need the... I don't need the demon orb.
I should be fine without it.
Yes.
Oh, him.
Okay, I have more sword.
Oh fuck!
I got camera'd again.
I always get camera'd!
It's not fair!
It's always a god damn!
Are you serious?
That's it.
Get over here.
I'm not fucking with you.
I can't.
You made me use too many heals.
I need these heals for the boss.
Not for this!
I'm a little scared.
He was very close to me.
There we go.
Okay.
All right.
Oh god.
Listen, Doki.
You don't understand.
It's on fire!
Toki.
It's on fire, Toki.
You don't understand.
It'd be so... It's gonna be so worth it.
Guys, is this the last level?
I need to know before I do anything.
Is this... I lost count.
Everything has actually... It's been a blur.
It's... It's really cool, Toki.
You don't understand.
Guys, I think I understand.
I don't know.
I don't know either!
I lost count!
I don't... I don't know too!
Oh no, I used all my magic.
Oh no.
JK!
Okay.
I just need this.
Before he gets closer, I just need this.
I don't think I have enough magic for this.
Oh no, I don't.
Guys!
Oh my god!
Oh my medicine!
Oh fuck!
It's okay.
I got this!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, not you.
Oh my god!
I actually needed that!
Holy fuck!
I needed that so badly!
Oh my god!
I don't know how I did it!
Oh fuck!
I don't know how I did that!
I actually don't know how I did that!
It's like a fucking god came over!
Oh my god!
Please, I need that magic!
I need that magic so badly!
Oh!
No, the magic despawned!
I'm so sad.
The magic despawned, guys.
The magic despawned!
Guys!
Oh my god, I don't have enough... I...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
This is not looking good.
I might have...
That is not looking good, guys.
It's not looking good for Doki right now.
Oh my god.
I don't know how... I wish I knew how I do these crits, guys.
I wish I know how I'm doing them.
Oh my god, though.
There's more.
I don't have any magic left.
Oh my god.
This is not good.
No!
Oh no!
I don't have gun!
There's no bullets!
There's no bullets.
There's no bullets in my gun.
There's no bullets in my gun, guys.
Oh my god!
No!
I got it!
I can't!
I had to!
It was the only way to live!
It was the only way!
You don't understand?
I will die if I didn't do it.
Oh my god!
I see my life flash by!
I see my life flash before I be right there.
Oh my god!
What do I do?
I'm fucking...
Oh my god!
It locked me in!
Guys!
I'm not even fighting the fucking boss that I'm using all my vids!
I'm so sad!
I'm not actually since then!
Oh my god!
Where am I?
No!
Get me out!
Here it is!
You guys could have told me I was level 20!
I swear to god...
Chat...
This sword...
Better be fucking worth it!
I swear to fucking god!
I...
Used up all my vids for this!
I swear to god!
Doki, you never asked!
Okay, maybe I should use the sword here?
Do I do it?
Do I use the sword here, chat?
Of course, it's worth it!
Look how cool it is!
Can I use the bathroom then I'll be right back?
All right, I'm back!
Power pose!
Solid!
Menlaire!
Bite size!
Alan, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
All right!
I'm using the sword!
I swear to god!
I swear to fucking god!
Where does this take me?
I swear to god!
If I'm gonna go to super hell, I...
No way!
Don't!
I swear...
I feel like one of you is lying!
I...
Why did one guy say...
No way!
Don't!
Why?
I...
You'll be fine!
I swear, this takes you to super hell, I...
There's so much.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Let's see all.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Thank God.
Fashionable goods, too.
Wow, look at all those medicine.
I got so much medicine.
Oh, my God.
Alright.
Go back.
Super hell-ass fashion.
Nice.
What is it?
What is it, Dad?
Come on.
I'm dreaming.
Oh, my God.
All my fucking items.
Oh, my.
All my items.
God.
Just like that.
Fucking super hell to have.
Alright.
Enhance.
Might as well enhance the fucking hammer.
Nice.
Alright.
I don't think I can make... I can level up my armor yet.
But, like...
It's just... I think we'll just... Oh, we did it!
Level 2!
Let's go!
Nice.
Level 2 armor.
There we go.
At least we got one level up on the armor.
Just one plus one defense.
It's the small things.
It's the small things in life.
Is it here?
Where?
What's here?
Oh, okay.
It's for the last orb.
Okay.
Alright.
No!
How are you alive?
No, not you!
No!
Oh, no!
Hehehehe.
I was immortal.
This is going to be alive.
Hehehehehe.
No!
How are you still alive?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright.
There you go.
Oh, my God!
What the fuck?
I just saw him!
Come on.
Where is this?
What the fuck?
Give me a sec.
What?
Where is he?
I can't see.
Woo!
I was like, where did he go?
Alright.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
I should have enough fire again.
Oh, I can't kill the legs?
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
I can't kill the legs.
I can't.
But my thing is always on the legs!
Okay.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Legs do nothing!
Hee hee hee.
Hee hee hee hee.
Wait.
Do I have enough for fire again?
Yes, I do.
Fire!
Yes!
That's right!
Kill him!
Yes!
You hit your last half!
Get out of here!
No more hee hee hee hee hee!
Huh.
Try to come back from that.
That's fucking right.
You hit your last half!
Hee hee hee.
Hee hee hee fucking hee.
Where the fuck is this goddamn hammer?
I'm so lost.
Alright, nice.
Where is this hammer?
What the fuck?
Okay, these cameras...
Fucking...
Wait, I already took it?
Oh, I already took it!
Okay, how do I get out of here?
Heh, finally!
He's dead, right, Toki?
Heh, he's dead this time, right?
Where the fuck is that door?
Is that the door?
Okay, the ladder.
There you go.
Okay, I should be able to enhance another...
Another armor thing.
I think.
Uhhh!
Yeah, I'll just do that.
Just...
To see if I can make it in time.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Okay, and then I'll save...
I should be super strong now.
Yes, the strength orb.
Give me the power!
The power!
You're alive?
Come with me.
I need Nobunaga to see this.
Yay!
She's alive!
I didn't know you survived.
I already moved on.
The slow-mo run.
Yeah, I was like, really?
I honestly thought she was gonna get shot by an arrow while she was running slow-mo to us.
It's time to go.
It was just such a good moment.
Why?
I thought she was gonna get shot.
I'll finish this.
Alone.
But I just got here!
Yeah.
You cannot be involved.
Your brother or me?
Who will you pick?
Me, of course.
I'm less evil.
And hot.
I...
Yeah?
Say it!
Let him hear.
No!
Did she say it?
I don't know if she, like, whispered it.
I hope you find happiness.
Wait, what?
This is not a rent-a-girlfriend.
You cannot reject it.
I hope you find happiness.
That's right.
I friend-zone you.
I hope Nobunaga heard this.
I broke your sister's heart.
That's right.
This is worse than me.
Than me.
Banging your sister.
I made her fall in love with me.
And then I broke her heart.
That's right, Nobunaga.
You saw that?
Now she'll always think about me.
No matter who she dates.
She'll always think about me.
That's hardcore.
That's right.
I broke your sister's heart.
I just transferred my power into this golden- Wait, that's what the statue was for?
Holy shit.
That's sad.
Oh my god.
It looks so evil.
Holy shit.
Look how evil this statue looks.
There.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Golden evil statue.
Oh, that statue does look super evil.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
You could be that this entire time?
Fire.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Oh, you think just cause you can fly?
Tornado.
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Wait.
How do I shoot that?
I didn't know.
Wait a minute.
What do I do now?
Okay.
That's fine.
I'll just do this.
I'll just do that.
Fire!
That's fucking right.
Oh.
Um.
So.
What do I do now?
Wait.
Does this hit him?
Oh, it does.
Nice.
Oh shit.
But that hits me.
Okay.
Uh.
Let's just use the medicine now.
Wait.
That doesn't hit him.
Wait a minute.
What the fuck do I do?
Do I just dodge?
Oh, I just dodge.
Okay.
Get down from here!
This should not have fixed camera angles.
I'm sorry, but like...
This...
That's actually bullshit.
Not gonna lie.
If anything, this fight should not have...
Oh my god.
What is he?
What?
Oh, keep hitting him.
Don't let him recover.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, now I know.
I don't know what that did.
I was like trying to hit him, but I felt like it didn't do anything.
I thought it didn't do anything at all there at first.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Oh no, not the tornado.
Please!
I have to deal with fixed camera angles!
This is not fair!
Oh my god.
My place!
I'm not trying to figure out where it's where!
Okay.
I'll use the hammer for this.
Am I...
Am I doing anything?
I can't...
I think I am!
Nice!
Wait, is...
Do I have enough for fire?
I do.
Fire!
Oh shit!
Okay, I think...
Okay.
What does he do?
Whoa!
Okay, I didn't know what that did.
Okay.
I swear to god.
Can I dodge that?
I SWEART!
Like...
I can't do anything about it!
I don't know what to do.
I...
Oh my god.
I literally have to...
Invin...
Frame him.
Right there.
I'm literally...
I...
Invincible framed him.
Right there.
Oh my god.
I...
I had to like...
Oh my god.
I used invincibility frame.
For him.
Oh shit.
That's stupid.
Fucking tornado.
Oh my god!
I...
I framed it!
Oh...
The fuck did he do?
What?
Be...
Be still.
Oh no.
How do I...
Did he pachinko?
Oh my god, the eclipse.
Don't stare at the eclipse, guys.
Unless you have your special glasses.
Huh?
I must believe in the only way.
Believe.
It will guide me!
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I'm digivolving.
Oh power rangers.
Oh you're captain planet!
Children!
Power up your rings!
How do I...
How...
I don't fucking know how to kill him.
I don't know how to kill him.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I literally...
Run around and I...
Okay.
This is our goofy boss fight.
Not gonna lie.
This...
This boss fight is so goofy.
What the...
Oh shit!
Oh I'm sorry!
I didn't...
I didn't touch that!
What?
I'm sorry.
I did not mean it like that.
I didn't mean it like that.
But like how do I kill that?
Like...
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
He runs at me.
What do I do when he does the laser move though?
Like what do I do?
Oh okay.
I walked to the side.
Okay.
Looks like you heard you.
What the fuck?
Just run to the side.
Okay.
Oh!
Run run run run run run run!
Whoa!
Wait what do I do here?
Oh!
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh I can block the fire attack?
Okay.
That's good to know.
I'm just gonna run.
I'm just gonna...
The side!
Okay.
I got his legs.
Got your legs!
Oh my god.
Just keep running.
Run to the side!
I got your arm!
Oh my god.
Just keep running.
Get off!
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
What?
Like what in my fight?
What the fuck?
Okay.
That's fine.
Wait what's that?
Wait what the fuck is that?
Oh shit!
Okay.
I got confused.
I didn't know what that fuck was.
Like it's understandable.
I got a little confused.
Okay.
Run to the side.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Shield.
Shield no no no no.
I could heal the time.
Oh my god.
I could shield the time.
Ah!
I don't have heals!
I actually don't have heals!
Please please please please please please I actually don't have any heals for this!
What?!
You got Soraka's Shield!
Noooo!
Oh my god, oh my god!
I have the Talisman!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I hate these guys!
Oh my god, no!
Oh my god!
No!
Holy shit!
These guys!
He's spamming attacks!
I don't know what to- No!
No!
Wait, EK's keepsake?
What does it do?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, that's so fair!
That's not fair!
That's actually not fair!
Oh my god!
I am saved!
I am- He
will rise again!
Oh thank god!
Thank you, EK!
Thank you!
I knew killing you was a good idea!
How'd he do it?
See, guys?
Killing him wasn't a mistake.
Oh!
Wait, what?
Oh my god, we did it!
Oh!
We fucking did it!
That was so scary!
I didn't think we were gonna make- We did it, guys!
That was genuine fear!
That was actual, genuine fear!
That's how it ends?!
He just runs?!
And he just- That's it?!
That's how it ends?!
My last health potion!
Oh!
You got the bad ending?
That's fine!
I got an ending!
Oh my god!
I'm so happy!
It's because I chose the wrong woman!
I didn't think- I didn't think- I didn't know I won't go back!
I didn't- I thought I would return to the village!
How was I supposed to know I got greedy?!
I wanted two women!
I was like, WHOA!
I wonder who that other woman was!
Oh, Jesus Christ!
That was- That was really fun!
That was a fucking weird-ass story!
But, like, I had a lot of fun!
I- I'm just surprised I remember nothing about this game!
I remember nothing about this game when I was growing up!
All- All- All I could remember was the village.
Like, I remember the village and the- The main character.
But, like, nothing else.
So, It's crazy, but- Because there was so many wild things going on in this game.
I don't understand how I could not remember anything from it.
Yeah, it was very historically accurate, chat.
But we did it!
We beat another game!
Oh!
That was really fun, though!
I had a- Oh, Dad wants to- Dad wants to pee, guys.
But thank you all...
Thank you all...
...for watching.
Is there an after credit scene, chat?
Chat, is there- Is there an after credit scene after this?
I- How could I for- I know, right?
How the fuck could I forget?!
Hee-hee-hee-hee-hee!
And the greatest swordsman of all time!
I can't believe I could forget- The greatest swordsman of all time.
Say his name, chat.
Say his name.
Gaugandantus is pretty memorable.
Of all demons.
How could you forget?
Gaugandantus!
The greatest swordsman of all demons.
Oh, I hope everybody names their children after Gaugandantus.
What a guy.
What a hero.
Anyway, guys.
I'm tired now.
I just need to know.
Is there an after-credits scene chat before I leave?
I just need to know that.
There is a small scene?
Alright, we'll wait for the after-credits.
I'm so tired.
Oh my god, I'm so tired.
You know, like, by the way, I had to, like, try and see, like, how long... Dad, please!
I'm almost done!
I have to see, like, no key!
Come on!
Okay, he's, like, extra demanding.
He was like, I need to pee!
I want to pee!
Okay, but, like, um... I... Oh my god, he lost my train of thought.
I actually...
Okay, I... Oh yeah, I looked up, like, no commentary walkthrough, like, just to see how far...
like, where I was at, and how far it was.
They finished this game in five hours.
I think...
I think... And then it took me, like, what?
Five, six, seven hours?
Seven to eight hours?
But yeah, they finished this game in five hours, and I was like, okay, to be fair, if you minus all the time it took me on puzzles, maybe... Maybe I would get close to that amount.
I don't know what I mean.
Come on.
Don't worry.
We're almost done.
Hey!
Hey, we're almost done.
Okay?
We're almost done.
Let's wait.
Five more...
I'm waiting for the after-credits scene!
Hang it!
Yeah, he did.
He went closer.
He was like, did you not hear me, bitch?
I need walkies now!
He was like, do you not hear me?
All right.
Please!
We're so close!
Give me five minutes!
We're in for five minutes!
We're almost there!
Oh, it's so... What happened to my robot horse?
I worked so hard for it!
What?
I worked so hard for... What happened to it?
No robot horse.
It really is the bad ending.
What the fuck?
Why is it a normal horse?
I put it in the stable and everything!
Me, thank you for the ten gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
There's no power relents to recharge it.
No!
Where is my electric car charger?
Look, I have to live with my mistakes, okay?
I didn't save scum because then I will never learn.
This is a lesson for me.
Never get too greedy.
This was a lesson.
At least I got a cool sword.
You never learn anyway!
You don't know that!
I learned... Don't worry, I finally will learn next time.
Next game, I'll learn.
I'll learn from my experience.
I'll remember my lesson.
Back to my stupid regular horse.
God damn it.
Oh, he's reborn as a crow!
I knew it!
There's a demon inside of all crows.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna head off now.
I'm sorry it's very abrupt ending, but...
Dad really wants his walkies, so I can't stall anymore for him.
But thank you all for coming, for watching me play on, uh...
Oh wait, what is this?
Oh, I guess I didn't see it.
Alright, play time.
Six hours.
There's...
Phantom Realm Floors.
51 saves.
Hey, B!
That's a pass!
Hey!
That's a pass, guys!
Oh, anyway, guys.
Um, it's great trying... playing Onimusha, too.
Um, I had a great time.
It's nice going through memory lane again, even though I forgot all my memories.
Of this game.
But, uh...
Thank you all for playing.
As always, everybody.
Stay high...
Oh, not play.
Thank you all for watching.
Sorry, I was the one that played the game.
Oh, thank you all for watching.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'm gonna go walk Dad now.
I'll see you guys next time.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Bye, everyone.
Bye!